I can't wait to see some of the comments
which is a whack job she's going to kill
people when people hear your story their
mind will go into a blender because they
can't compute smoke may come out of
their ears because they're like wait a
second there is somebody who is a
conservative gay who now has decided
maybe they're not gay who also has had a
career in Tech but also is interested in
iridology and then also is
non-judgmental of other people like when
you add all that up it's like wait I
thought that like conservatives were
supposed to do this or liberal was
supposed to do this or I thought gays
this or or straight people like if you
literally ask me how many people check
all those boxes like I've met one person
in my life we're a wild card for sure
yeah
what's up guys bang bang I'm here with
Elle uh the reason why I want to do this
entire conversation is because I saw
online uh iridology or iridology
depending on how you want to pronounce
it
um and I was like what the hell is this
I went down this deep deep rabbit hole
and I feel like I now uh have such a
small amount of information about a
really important topic that I forgot to
go and I'd find somebody who actually
understands what they're talking about
so let's just start with like what is
this did people are taking pictures of
your eyes and they could tell how
healthy you are yeah or how unhealthy
you are okay depending right so uh the
great thing about the eyes is it is the
only soft tissue analysis that exists at
present today right uh it's it's
extremely accurate and it depends on all
the nerve endings communicating to the
iris or the eyeball
and I I always akin to think about a
cell phone right uh you know processing
you have your software everything's
communicating in this device how the
hell would you even know what this
information is how to access it unless
you had a screen and that's how the eyes
are similarly uh so the eyes are the
screen the eyes are the screen it's
receiving all this information and it's
basically telling us and this is real
and it's historic okay so this is like
we're gonna go very dumb questions
throughout this entire conversation
because I don't have any good questions
but if we start with I see people
sometimes they have like yellow eyes and
so you have like really white eyes I'm
assuming that is a piece of this but
really you're talking about there's the
iris of the eye and then there's like
the color of the eye and all these
things can you help me understand like
what is feeding into this like screen
that is the eye sure so uh taking it
super basic
you're correct every any time you see
these different colorations or you know
black spots and whatnot in the eye
that's simply the state of the tissues
and the lymphatic system as a whole you
know the the iris or rather the colored
part of the eye gives you an entire
picture of the entire system the entire
body uh there's really only two colors
of eyes and there's different schools of
thought depending on the iridology
source that you look into uh you know
myself my mentor and the pioneer of
iridology Dr Bernard Jensen subscribe to
there are only two colors only two eye
colors only two eye colors okay and
we've proven this over and over again
with all the obviously the eyes that
we've taken and the Deep detoxes and
cleansing that we've done and we've
noticed the changes in them we've only
ever seen two colors and that's brown
and blue and the variations you can go
you know dark blue you can go light blue
dark brown light brown so no green or
anything no green so that's a great
question because you know anytime we see
green when you take a picture of it
really closely
you can always see the true color with
the proper light you can see the true
color I I say look at the sky if there's
tons of clouds covering the sky you
can't see blue
and ultimately you want to see that blue
sky
right so we the the clouds are simply
lymphatic congestion waste that the body
hasn't eliminated are green eyed people
unhealthy is that what you're saying uh
you know I
that sounds like a yes I have a really
hard time calling anyone unhealthy right
it's because when you when we approach
bodies from a cellular detoxification
standpoint we always go down to the the
very base of that and that's how strong
your genetics how strong is your
cellular structure and you can see that
within the iris you know and if you get
uh look at you know some of the pictures
that have taken you see these very you
know thin white lines or hopefully just
thin lines throughout the eye uh they
kind of look like you know spider webs
almost but they should be kind of
straight and and close together you
don't want to see them all crazy wonky
that would show the person's cellular
strength so I can sit here and say yeah
maybe you've eaten like [__] and you've
got all this backup but underneath all
this you have a very strong cell
structure and for all intents and
purposes you're healthy you just yeah
this is interesting because uh to
describe the process itself you
basically are taking uh a camera it
could be a cell phone own or it could be
a specialized camera technology are
putting it very very close to the
eyeball you're taking a photo of the eye
uh I'm gonna think of it as like under a
microscope essentially is you're able to
see very close
um to what's going on in the eye and
it's one thing to be like oh your
current state of your lymphatic system
we'll talk about that in a second what
that is but also you're saying that you
can understand the genetics of someone
right
how is that possible
uh so the
I mean the body is an amazing thing it's
an amazing machine and if if you
consider that the nerves are constantly
communicating with one another right so
we're built inside the womb
uh that obviously is a genetic mixture
between Mom and Dad or you know it's
always Mom and Dad whether
however you went about they're trying to
change that oh well yeah and that's
different conversation
it's one way of fashion the other how
you got around to getting that that baby
formed you're always going to have those
genetic uh dispositions that are passed
down through the generations okay and
that's all they are are dispositions
could you go in and help fix genetics
sure would that take an immense amount
of time and you're really gonna have
probably no fun in this lifetime every
anything outside of a you know piece of
fruit sure but that's not what we're
here to do we're here to enjoy uh so
when we look at genetic dispositions
they show up in the eye very clearly and
you can tell the length of how long that
genetic disposition or genetic inherent
weakness has been in the family right so
uh I always tell my clients don't get
freaked out if you see a genetic
weakness because ultimately what you
what we're gonna do or what you don't
want to do is give it the environment to
open Pandora's box right so that's what
we focus on so I try I always say look I
can see the genetic dispositions uh I
can see how strong the genetics have
been throughout your family but don't
let that deter you because ultimately
it's going to come down to your specific
system and what terrain you're giving it
to either come out or not this may sound
kind of weird but like I almost think
that you're describing in a way of like
you have this disposition and then what
you do in your lifetime can turn it on
or off almost like a light switch is
that a fair way to think about it yeah
and that and and I mean coming from the
physical side obviously there's there's
give and take on what you put in your
body there's cause and effect always
right if you throw in a bunch of you
know certain mucus forming Foods or what
we call acid Ash forming Foods you're
going to see some some bad effects if
you put in great magnetics you know
fruits berries melons some veggies
you're going to see some butter but then
there always comes down to the
non-physical component of that as well
if you sit in fear right mentality is a
huge intention is huge when it comes to
your outlook of your health
because everything physical has a
non-physical component
and you're worried I'm gonna get
dementia I'm going to get dementia Dada
dementia Grandpa dementia most likely
you're going to create your own reality
depending on how you know
it doesn't really matter necessarily so
there's always two factors too like your
mind can basically turn some of this
stuff on uh in like a really weird way
if you have uh anxiety and you keep
saying hey I I'm anxiety I have a high
anxiety I have high anxiety that can
lead to actually getting more and more
anxiety but the same thing could happen
with things that people would consider
more kind of uh medical
um you know ailments or things like
dementia Etc is the more you think about
it actually the more that you increase
the odds you're going to get it right
and there's people who and and that's
why I always say that whenever in my
opinion when we approach individuals who
are they're they're ready to be well
they want to feel better they or they
want to get ahead of some of these
things they've watched mom and dad
Grandpa Grandma great grandpa they don't
want to continue that on and or they're
wanting to bring life into this Earth
and they want to make sure they don't
pass that down to their kids
when we get those people it's important
to always address that non-physical
component to get the mentality on board
with the physical uh detoxification
process or whatever that may be because
if they don't they're not ready mentally
emotionally
it's not going to be as effective
physically and so that's how I approach
it with what is the lymphatic system
because this is how I discovered this
entire New World
um and I should call out like there's a
lot of people I asked before uh we had
this conversation and like it was pretty
split half people were like this is
complete nonsense like this doesn't work
it's not real medicine then there's
another group of people who are like no
no this is exactly kind of what you're
talking about like the eyes hard the
screen uh everything that happens within
your body can be seen in the eye and
really my understanding is that the eyes
are a reflection of what's going on in
the lymphatic system for people who uh
kind of do this but I don't know what
the lymphatic system sure
so lymphatic system is your sewer system
okay simple simply put uh so everything
that you you yourself eat and excrete so
do your cells so all the systems in the
body
depend on the lymphatic system working
very well right whether that's your
endocrine system so glands hormones
um ultimately your 85 percent of your
excuse me 75 of your health equation
depends on the stadium lymphatic system
so when we look at a lymphatic system
it's simply the digestion
right kidneys adrenals uh obviously
liver pancreas but the state of those
depend on the sewer system so it's all
the pipes making sure everything gets
passed down the biggest components to
lymphatic system are obviously you know
lymph nodes
and then the
um the ability to the cells carrying you
know into the kidneys to then go out
through the elimination you know
right so but unless you have the
filtration down unless you have the Lim
the lymph nodes working well
everything's communicating and dumping
into the kidneys and then going out
through you know urine or poop right
then if those are down good luck that's
where we start to see some of those
issues
what changes the
state of this makes it a good lymphatic
system or a bad lymphatic is the things
that you eat is it activities you do is
it genetics like like what kind of puts
you in a good State there or a bad State
yeah hey guys what's going on I hope
that you're enjoying this conversation
but I want to interrupt for a quick
second and tell you about a brand new
conference that I'm hosting on March 4th
at the Miami Beach Convention Center the
event is called lyceum Miami and tickets
are completely free for anyone who wants
to come I'm bringing together many of
the most popular guests from the podcast
over the last couple of years some of
the guest speakers that we've already
announced are people like Vivek
ramaswamy from strive asset management
ordelion and Mike Solana from Founders
fund Chris Williamson from the modern
wisdom podcast Cody Sanchez from
contrarian thinking and billionaire
Christian augermeyer among many others
I've got a number of amazing surprise
guests as well some that you definitely
will not expect and others that come
from walks of life that you will be
scratching your head as to how I even
got them to show up but come check out
lyceum Miami on March 4th the lyceum was
a public gym in Athens Greece where
people used to come together talk about
ideas and debate topics that were
important to society I want to meet
people in person in real life once again
after three years of a Hiatus from real
life events and so I'm hosting the event
and as I mentioned anyone from anywhere
can come to this event completely for
free all you need to do is go to
lyceummiami.com and you'll be able to
pick up a free general admission ticket
make sure you claim your ticket in order
to get in through the doors lyceum Miami
is going to be a great time so come
check it out come hang out with me many
of the popular guests from the podcast
and other like-minded individuals lyceum
Miami March 4th Miami Beach Convention
Center I hope to see you there all right
let's get back into this conversation uh
a few factors one must say the things
that make the most impact are the diet
right what you put in your body which
can be liquids chemicals Pharmaceuticals
whether that herbs whatever it is so
anything you can take in the body
um and then again genetics don't play
too much part in that because those are
already inherent weaknesses it's whether
or not you are on more the acid side of
chemistry or you want more close to that
Bay Side of chemistry what what is that
sure for space so there's only two sides
of chemistry
acids are the the corrosive the things
that break things do you know if you
think about acid right it's it's uh look
at Coke drop a cornflake and Coke good
luck right that's low PH it's about
three pH
uh that's what breaks down tissues
but when you look at acid levels in the
body there should only be one place
where there's acid and that's in the
stomach chamber right breaking down to
break down food
I basically I'm gonna have a biology
degree
I'm really like getting my nerd out here
so uh so you want to keep that at a
certain level of ass you don't want to
mess with that acid chamber right you
want to go too crazy high up you don't
want to go either way because nature
doesn't like extremes it doesn't like
high acidity and it doesn't like high
alkalinity it wants base closer to
alkaline chemistry but everything that
we talk about when it comes to lymphatic
system is what happens in the body so
you could look at something like an
apple you could look at something like a
piece of meat
and uh they've done tests where they'll
measure the acidity level or its energy
Factor uh frequency outside the body and
then when you put it inside the body how
does the body change when that food is
then broken down and digested
um obviously the faster burning foods
are going to be a less acidic process in
the body and cause less waste or left
over right and then of course that's
more towards your fruits berries melons
some veggies and herbs and so forth High
magnetics
super acidic is going to be that you
know the the dairies uh Meats cheeses
stuff like that uh starches heavy starch
and then of course you know your your
drugs and alcohols and such like that so
there's always these levels
when you're looking at the body it's
very simple when you look at chemistry
there's always just two sides so the
body's either on one side or the other
and I would say this the majority of
individuals are sitting in that acidic
side because
of our diet not what we're taught and so
let's go through maybe a bunch of
different types of foods real quick and
you can kind of help me understand like
maybe it's not as black and white as
good or bad but just like uh more or
less maybe it's a better way to think
about it so I'm guessing candy ice cream
like things that we would consider
desserts or sweets are bad
they do they do leave the acidic Ash
they will cause you to go into the acid
side okay and Dairy is also included
that because things like ice cream are
are full of dairy and all that so it's
kind of like in the same type of
category okay uh meat meat is a big one
because there's a lot of people who I've
talked with carnivore diet uh the
um protein heavy diet uh keto we can go
through all the different variations uh
it is probably the number one diet that
people have come on here and talked
about and been like this is what I eat
so forget what they think the benefits
are or whatever it's like what they
actually eat themselves what are the
pros and cons of those types of uh kind
of just dietary regimens sure
uh I'll set this as a as a
foundational point
again going back to there's physical and
then there's the non-physical component
to this
I will say that
there are foods
and chemistry that once put in the body
are going to render a result whether you
believe it or not right it's just
science it's proper chemistry proper
physics
then there's the side of what your
intention is in your relationship with
that right the majority of individuals
are doing things because they feel they
should because they feel forced to they
feel that it will get a certain result
and they're not necessarily in alignment
with it and so I always give that caveat
because what I don't want to ever tell
someone is well don't eat this because
it's bad I don't know their relationship
without food I don't know where they are
you know intentionally and emotionally
with that they may do very well this is
why we can see people who you sit there
and go they should have [__] died
years ago they eat like [__] they take
all this stuff they smoke drink yet
they're still up and running and you
know in late 90s how are they not dead
yet Warren Buffett I don't know if he
smokes and drinks but that dude eats
McDonald's and drinks Coca-Cola and eats
See's Candy like every single day I
don't know how he's still alive these
are these individuals that I say this
comes back to always consider the
intention that man has no resistance
whatsoever towards that food he is in
alignment this is what I eat this is
what I like and this is what fuels my
body it's crazy now if we open the
[__] up she probably looks like
crap but he's a happy wealthy successful
and he is in alignment with his life so
this is why I'm very careful about
saying hey don't do that that's bad this
is good this is the only way to get
there there's always the roads to
whatever outcome we're looking for kind
of what works for you yes but if we're
just going to talk chemistry in physics
then there's little to no benefit of
eating a dead piece of Flesh
because when you look at the actual
biology of a human uh we're a species
not one person eats differently than the
other person based on a blood that the
blood type doesn't matter because again
blood is only 25 of this equation all it
does is carry nutrients back forth
that's it
um it always comes down to what's built
for our our biology and we are built as
more frugivore type beings right you
look at our teeth structure you look at
our our spine you look at the fact that
we don't have uh smooth intestinal
tracts we have very pocketed intestinal
tracts so we don't process meat very
well at all as compared to a cat who's
the only really true carnivore on this
planet they just have a cat a cat so the
felines are the only true carnivore if
you look at their intestinal tract it's
very smooth just to pass that protein
down they need minimal uh I think that
the thing about protein that everyone's
going for is I would love to see us get
to a point of Consciousness where we
start changing what how we are getting
those amino acids I would love for
people to start saying amino acids
because that's really what they're going
for amino acids are the building blocks
you get these you know we get
bodybuilders all the time and we're
fixing them up after they've gone and
built themselves to a certain degree but
their kidneys are shutting down because
that's what proteins do can you be a
bodybuilder and not eat meat absolutely
go look at um there's a a few amazing
and fruititarian on Instagram he's
uh my uh I can't remember his last name
I think it's Delgado but namai he's
never eaten a piece of meat in his life
the man is huge how do you do that oh
look at a gorilla ask the gorilla you
see this all over the place now ask a
gorilla where he gets his meat and after
he's done tearing your head off
deal that you know it was that tree over
there
when you break down chemistry you've got
to look at the way our body uses it and
and when you eat a piece of meat I get
what you're going for but it would be
better on your system and healthier and
would actually have a faster effect if
you just went straight to amino acids
which are the tissue building chemistry
so what's fascinating about the
different dyes let's just take
vegetarian versus like a carnivore diet
it's kind of two versions of different
extremes
um both of them actually have some
commonality which is don't eat a lot of
like chocolate and candy and ice cream
and like all like the bad stuff don't
need a lot of processed food right it's
almost like within the bucket of clean
eating some people go extreme on
vegetarian some go extreme on the
carnivore diet but actually the like
zero to one Leap is like leave the
modern diet behind of processed food and
all the uh processed sugars and things
like that and just start eating clean
and then the variations there yes there
are differences people disagree with
them maybe it's because of their body
maybe it's because of how they feel or
their their relationship but actually
it's not as big of a difference between
vegetarian meat as it is processed first
non-processed diet is that like a fair
way to think about it that's very fair
that's why you get a lot of people
saying well I went vegan have you seen
some of the vegan food It's Time food
it's not even real uh the body doesn't
understand how to break down complex
chemistry you know it's the it's the
same as going in seen one of these you
know not to put down any certain brands
but you just look at the structure of
the Beyond Burger the body doesn't know
what to do with this just like it
doesn't know what to do with straight
magnesium supplements what happens when
somebody eats one of those Beyond
Burgers oh God uh is it soy based
there's our or they're they have a
different uh they have a pea protein
which I don't know Knox P protein I
think that if um again it depends on
what your outcome is if I have an
individual that's like look I'm not
ready to get down to these issues and
fix these I'm I need to go perform and
go model and body build and win the
competition
cool then I would rather you do that
with a pea protein as opposed to a whey
protein why because again ways that
Dairy base which is acidic and it's
going to cause all the mucus for me
which is just going to end up breaking
down your tissues so I tell people if
you're going to build build correctly
and if you must build and you need to
get that fast then go pee Protein that's
not an isolate because then give your
kidneys a break a little bit but most of
these bodybuilders we end up getting
after they're done with their career per
se or a lot of the athletes Because by
the time they're done if they don't keep
moving and keep living off the uh the
epinephrine and basically all the the
steroids that the animal gives out when
it's when it's killed uh then all those
acids settle in and that's why you start
to see some of these bodybuilders and
athletes really you know [__] hits the
fan after they're done moving after
they're done with their career so we
gotta kind of cleanse them and rebuild
them yeah what um what's fascinating is
uh there's a race car driver a couple
years ago I forget exactly who it was
but um he went so fast so often that his
body got used to having higher
adrenaline levels yeah uh and that was
kind of like his base level and then uh
when he retired naturally the adrenaline
levels dropped and the body literally
thought that he was dying yeah and so it
sort of shut down all the internal
organs I remember reading about it and
just being like whoa like that that is
something where obviously this guy
unintentionally trained his body to
operate with a base level of adrenaline
so much higher uh than where it
naturally was that when he returned back
to the base level the body basically
panicked didn't know what to do with it
and so what you're describing is not
necessarily just adrenaline but these
other things that people do to their
bodies whether it's whey protein or
others that they're doing for either
competitive reasons or lifestyle reasons
that when they try to get off of it it
actually causes uh huge problems for
them yeah yeah anytime again the body
wants to find homeostasis that's just
its nature and so any time when we stop
that activity it all that's what we say
is we give it until it she hits the van
um but I would say like you got an
individual like him whose nervous system
is completely down something we can also
see in the eye if you look at an eye and
you see like these uh you know you cut a
tree and you see the Rings inside the
tree to figure out how old it is well
similarly the eyes have these Rings or
indents and it indicates someone whose
nervous system is down or it struggles
and that comes from a lot of high
stimulants uh High meat because again
steroids epinephrine adrenaline from
that animal uh flesh or you know just
High adrenaline when you're doing your
work in your activities and God bless
them you came here to have a [__]
great time in life and experience
everything but it also sometimes takes
that huge toll and that's that's another
reason why we're here because we want
those people to continue to enjoy their
lifestyle
looking at a tree and understanding the
age of it after you've cut through it
and also looking at the eye uh is there
some connection there from like a
biological standpoint like that that's
like a very different thing that I think
most people would ever uh assume are
related is your eyeball and a tree yeah
but like that does make a lot of sense
right if you're able to tell the age
based on an eye and you're able to tell
it on a tree like what what is the
connection sure I would say that stress
ages you right so stress just causes
morcidity and if you look at the tree
even though the tree is not necessarily
stressed per stay but you could see that
within different environments depending
on the age of that tree there's going to
be more of those and basically that tree
is getting to its point where it then
expires to a degree she's never really
truly die you know their roots and
continue to communicate with the others
but when it comes to a human those those
Rings indicate that level of stress and
I'm going to assume that person is aging
faster than they really are
their age per se so this lymphatic
system let's say that I eat horribly I'm
eating uh all the foods I'm not supposed
to eat I'm super stressed out I drink
all the time I'm doing drugs like
literally everything I don't work out
like I just the absolute opposite of
what I'm supposed to do yeah what is
happening to my lymphatic system and
then like how is that showing up
obviously we're talking about the eyes
but are there other things that uh if
I'm watching or listening to this I can
like immediately just tell like my
lymphatic system's messed up is it the
color of my skin or what else can I see
that that is showing the wear and tear
on my body sure
um always look at the skin
the skin never lies uh it is the third
kidney so when we again go back to that
sewer system and the kidneys are down
then the rest of the systems are
suffering because your trash isn't
getting taken out so it's just backing
up right
um but if those kidneys are down then
the skin takes over hopefully right if
you look at the if you have a dark green
like you can see my eyes have a darker
ring around the color part of you know
my Iris
means that it's a little tougher for me
to sweat through my skin which if I
can't eliminate through my kidneys then
I need to go sweat right because that's
the other way so a lot of people will
start to see the acid start to affect
the skin right look at eczema and so
forth
um digestion is a great way to find out
where you are
um if you're having issues or pain there
that should not be a painful process it
should also be a daily process but I
can't tell you how many people don't
[__] on a daily and I sit there and go
oh so how long has that been sitting
there and you know obviously putrifying
and so forth
um so all right hold on
pooping is a topic that I actually uh am
fascinated by because I saw a commercial
um this is maybe four or five years ago
and I thought it was the dumbest thing
in the world and then I went on mine
with down this super deep Rabbit Hole I
love how you do rabbit hole as usual as
usual I was like oh that actually makes
a lot of sense which was
um I'm gonna forget the name of the
device but basically it's like when you
sit on the toilet there's a like a stool
that you like would pull up and you
would put your feet on it so it would
raise your feet like six inches eight
inches off the ground it looked like and
their argument was it puts your body in
a more natural position to poop which is
more akin to you know if you went
outside and you just squatted down right
rather than having your knees at a 90
degree angle you actually were more at
like a 45 degree angle and their claim
which again I I have no clue if it uh is
true or not was that most people are
walking around with like multiple pounds
of waste that is in their body that does
not come out of their body because
they're pooping incorrectly which on its
face is like an absurd claim and I was
like that sounds like a great question
and then when I started looking at it
and like actually there was like a lot
of academic research that was explaining
like there might be more to this than
you would think and so let's just maybe
talk about like the health of pooping I
love it what exactly should someone be
doing and like how often what are like
warning signs versus maybe things were
like oh I'm like my body's you know
doing well yeah uh first of all I did
not think we're gonna talk about this
today wait until we get further
you know I have to say I never thought
didn't actually be talking about this
especially on a podcast I was the most
squeamish child you couldn't talk about
crap you couldn't tell I couldn't look
at dead bodies I could barely look at
eyes when I first saw him as a kid
um to now we're we're getting into it so
I love it
uh the obviously there's different
levels your ultimate desire is you've
received you see an animal a dog take a
dog for example they're mono eaters they
eat pretty much the same thing every
single day
um food in food out and that's how it
should be and I'm not saying it should
be rushing out of you that's a different
problem it's 30 minutes after you eat
you should be needing to go right 30
minutes but that's if you're eating the
proper diet right for that type of
digestion for our biology
95 of people are not so I would love to
see people get there but let's be
realistic what you're looking for is
really understanding the combinations of
food and what to put together and what
not to put together and this is stuff
we've known for Millennials right these
are these are things that even the the
the beginning of time knows what not to
mix so
uh when you look at food and the way it
breaks down the system if you eat a
protein or a flesh and you eat a starch
which is every single one of our meals
out there right fish and chips Pizza
burgers burgers all of it that cancels
out digestion because carbs digest in
the mouth
and the rest of it digests in the
stomach right the acid chamber to break
down you know the starch and stuff like
that
so
when we intake that it takes about a
good 24 to 48 hours to properly break
that down so the majority of individuals
are constipated
they're constipated up to the point
again we have like what 20 to 25
depending on who you are uh feat of
intestines so you imagine it's going
through the system but it's not getting
there properly it's not breaking down
properly so if we just took an average
American we snapshot said time out yeah
snapshot the intestine system you're
arguing that potentially there could be
a day or two worth of food that is still
somewhere in that intestine intestinal
oh now if you want to talk pocketed
digestion like we have there's years
years of years
it uh there's so one of my favorite
books you're scaring me so much one of
my favorite books in the world and most
people know about this book um but it's
like my Bible it's called outwitting the
Devil by Napoleon Hill
and in this book The Devil just the the
conversation with this uh lower uh
vibrational entity if you will is if a
man got one whiff of his sewer system he
would probably throw up and pass out and
basically want to die but he would
switch his lifestyle up quickly
again when we look at all this state of
the body
what we put in it based on our diet that
we encourage people to eat in the
society uh everything starts to acidify
so it's like setting fire to it and it
becomes this like mucoid plaque in the
the pockets of our digestion so uh
years and just keep stuffing and
stuffing and going in there and
eventually what we have uh in the eye is
called a malabsorption ring and if you
get really close in the the little
circle around the pupil so the black
part of the the iris
you'll see like this faint little border
and that's basically how backed up an
individual is in their intestinal tract
and we're talking we've my clients and
I've had it you know when I've done my
detoxing my clients have pulled out what
we call mugoid plaque and it's long
strings that look like tar
how does that come out of their body
they poop it out just like worms come
out of their body wow yeah just it just
comes right out but it hurts because
yeah in the picture of the eye you can
basically tell to a degree how backed up
someone's intestines are yeah and that
could go back the the like clogging of
it could literally be years years I've
had I've had people who you know
obviously by the time they are hitting
their 50s they're like I can't live in
this pain anymore I can't [__] for four
days I've got nothing but migraines
right which is all just connected from
the GI tract and so
we go and put I I asked their diet and
if I look at their diet there's no way
there's no way they eliminated that
because again proper chemistry and
physics and the law of nature says those
don't digest so what does the body do
the acids chew it up and store it
somewhere it's trying to move but it
doesn't get anywhere right because the
body just can't process that so yeah so
you take a picture of someone's eye and
again some people don't think that any
of this works sure
the more you're talking the more I'm
like okay I want you to take a picture
of my eye oh yeah we are absolutely oh
and if you can tell that somebody is
very backed up or has a lot of this like
plaque that you're describing how do you
get it out you keep mentioning detox uh
what do you do are you like putting
something in their body that like
flushes them out like what's going on so
the only the only way to get at this
level of cleansing is fruits berries
melons and really just that's all they
eat that's it in in herbs we have
obviously herbs that help with that
because you could do fruits berries and
melons and when we talk about getting at
these levels and we're really digging
into the systems and trying to cleanse
we're we're going towards more the
astringent type fruits or the hard
pulling and that's like your dark grapes
your watermelons your citrus those are
really aggressive and they pull it's
just I always tell people you look at
your shower after you know when you go
to wash it do you grab the olive oil or
do you grab the lemon juice will you
grab the lemon juice because that's what
gets the scum right you need something
that digs in breaks all down and then
flushes it out so that's the only way to
get through that is really get to the
herbs and the fruits berries and melons
to really reach that and cleanse it
okay how long do you have to eat
basically I'm going to call this the
detox diet how long do you have to eat
this before it actually has an impact it
really depends on the person it depends
on the state of lymphatic system again
we're all built the same way give or
take you know some people we've had
clients that come in some people are
born without kidney like a kidney or or
I have client who they diverted
digestion bypass stitched and it's just
so it's a little different so every
single person is going to be slightly
different depending on the state of
their organs and so forth but also the
state lymphatic system I've seen people
have within one to two weeks they're
like you know I had one guy I read his
eyes and I'd never seen anything like
this I showed it to my mentor never in
his all his years has ever seen anything
like this
his stomach area in his eye looked like
our brain matter
and it was freaked me the hell out I was
like dude
I don't know I I need a moment with this
and I like stepped away for a second and
I thought this kid is riddled with worms
he's just packed with him now he is a if
you looked at him physically he's like a
model-esque body ripped
just beautiful guy and I'm like I'm
gonna need you to do something I'm gonna
need you to do a stomach cleanse within
a week kid calls me [__] out worms
left and right
big meat eater
parasites any flesh carries those
parasites even fruit carries that but
unless you give those parasites more to
eat
then there's that so I I have a dumb
question uh what are worms like in your
stomach yeah is it like actual yeah
actual worms there's different types
okay tapeworm is probably the most
well-known one I've heard of that one
you know we used to thankfully tell
women to ingest those to lose weight you
know yeah really oh yeah it was a big
thing I think in the 20s or 30s
we told women if they wanted to lose
weight just ingest the tapeworm and
let's
you know this is this is what I always
tell people this is the level of
Consciousness that we've gotten to and
and I love man's a desire to be
you know uh to to innovate and find new
ways and Pioneer I love that's just our
nature we're just such curious beings
but sometimes Theory
doesn't work with the law of Nature and
doesn't work with actual true science
and this and this is why I don't fault
MDS who don't know about the lymphatic
system because they weren't taught
there's you won't see me going to get a
medical degree because that that's not
even going to teach me exactly how this
Body Works they're taught how to treat
how to get you know certain results in a
certain amount of time and they have to
see a ton of people I can't fault them
for not knowing about a lymphatic system
but I'll tell you this why are they not
taught about it I don't understand
I I think it goes back to his
Consciousness I think we've gotten to
the let's
treat rather than cure the body knows
what to do we don't cure anybody the
body's already naturally detoxing the
body already knows how to cure itself
you have to give it the right
environment and the right properties to
do that the problem is we man gets too
much in their mind and they think that
sounds great that piece of meat tastes
really good but it doesn't make any
sense like the con I'd like to believe
that we have a little more common sense
we weren't given anything to murder an
animal we weren't given anything to
digest that that meat down but we do it
because again we're just trying to find
different ways and we got out of our
natural habitat we moved into colder
regions we know what the [__] to do
because there's no fresh food it's all
dead by the white death snow so
your next animal I just think that we've
moved our Consciousness further away
from science what would you say there's
a lot of people are going to watch this
and be like this is complete nonsense I
love it you know and I invite that a lot
because I eat meat every day and my
ancestors ate me and uh that's what
humans were supposed to do basically
like the carnivore yeah diet folks what
is like the counter argument to them
right because they're pointing and
they're saying this is how the ancestors
ate this is exactly what uh humans have
been doing for thousands of years and
like actually uh we shouldn't be eating
all the processed stuff but like eat
meat not just fruits berries melons Etc
like how do you kind of have a
conversation with those people um
foreign
I basically say what's your goal are you
eating because it
you have you enjoy the taste of that you
know I'm not telling anyone don't eat
something because you know
or rather avoid something
that tastes good just because it's going
to do well in the body because again
this is this is our playground this is
what we came here to do is explore taste
and joy so
there's that but I would say if your
goal is to have a vitality
filled life Vitality where I'm going to
live for a long time I'm not gonna have
any aches and pains I'm going to be you
know spelled and I'm not going to break
down I'm not going to have tissues yada
yada all this type of stuff
then you would know what side of
chemistry to eat but if you're just like
[__] it I want to travel everywhere I
want to go hunting I want to eat this
because it's fun fantastic I will always
come down to what is your intention in
life what do you truly want and
I think most people you know most of my
clients I get are in their you know late
30s into their 50s 60s because they're
at this point where they're going oh I
played around enough and now I'm
starting to feel those effects so now
can I switch that up and that's and it
simply is this I'm not saying never eat
meat again I come from just the
detoxification standpoint clean up the
system if you're seeing ailments come to
us we'll help you you know give you the
information and I'm gonna Choose Your
Own Adventure Time person go out there
and choose ultimately you're the only
one that's going to feel the effects so
what's fascinating is what you're
talking about is actually more in line
from the things that I've seen around
optimizing for longevity so if you want
to be a bodybuilder uh I think that
there's a very small audience that's
like you should be a bodybuilder and you
should be a vegetarian or you should be
only eating fruit or whatever right like
for whatever reason right or wrong uh
people associate build muscle especially
immense amount of muscle like a
bodybuilder uh with protein Meats Etc if
you go and you just say hey I am
optimizing for living as long as
possible and living as healthy as
possible during that standpoint the
research that I've seen is like eat
about 1200 calories a day uh eat a lot
of like leafy greens uh fish some meat
but like it is very much uh kind of what
I would consider like maybe vegetarian
plus right is it like I just invented
that term but like I think that's kind
of what it is is like eat a lot of like
vegetables uh salad type you know leafy
greens uh some fruits and then
supplement it with some meat on top of
the salad or whatever uh you know shrimp
fish all that stuff but it's low calorie
and it is what I would consider like a
much lighter Foods than it would be
Meats Etc and so like going back to this
idea of like what are you optimizing for
somebody who is optimizing for the
longevity how much of this has to do
with uh like inflammation in the body
and things that I'm assuming are
associated with the lymphatic system uh
you see people like Tom Brady who's like
I don't eat I think tomatoes and you're
like that sounds weird he's like no it
actually inflames the body
is this all connected and it's literally
just like what are you optimizing for
always really always it
when you uh when you choose certain
goals
right always choose the chemistry that
aligns with that the going back to the
whole Theory like okay concentrate on
calories it's going to be better for you
break it down a little more keep going
that's all I keep going down to the
science of it is if you kept digging
like like I've done for years I went I
always ask why why that why would you
put that on top of that well why would
you cook the salmon that way not this
way I literally I think my first word
out of my mouth as a child was why
and it got me down to straight chemistry
and physics and ultimately
what is it that you desire if you desire
to not have pain and you just you want
to feel you're light skinny glowing skin
and
that's all you ever want then you're
gonna be on the fruits berries melons
and you know some herbs and maybe and no
meat
no
could you eat a piece did you eat some
could you eat some and still be okay
sure absolutely
um it's it's not if you eat this and
you're gonna die it's over time that
really makes the biggest difference it's
like compounding basically compounding
because again chemistry is always going
to be has the time Factor
and most of us get into the hypnotic
rhythm of just eating the food that our
families our friends eat right because
we harmonize naturally as beings so
we're going to eat what our parents
friends love her and so this is why it's
a big deal with your people around you
sometimes it's harder to be a fruitarian
in this world why because one where the
[__] are you gonna go what are you gonna
do for fun what are you gonna go travel
and be like I need an apple I'm
literally laughing because as a kid
growing up we had cereal every morning
because yeah peanut butter and jelly for
lunch and we grew up in an Italian
household where we ate at like 8 P.M uh
really heavy like pastas uh and various
Italian dishes yeah and like it was
awesome right it tasted amazing and then
we'd have ice cream at the end right
like it was amazing it was like sounds
like my house same thing um it's and um
like I said I I really battle because
I'm not one of those purest individuals
you know like I said I love I love my
mentor and I completely appreciate where
it is coming from I didn't come here to
just be a fruititarian and sit on a
Mountaintop then what is the difference
and vegetarian is it just literally one
eats fruit pretty much any other eats
vegetables with maybe some fruits yeah
so a fruititarian I mean I went fruit
Italian for a year after being
vegetarian so no flesh whatsoever for
four years and then I went fruitarian
because I do to myself prior to going
out there and telling people here here's
a great thing to do and is that what you
eat now is fruit Italian I've gone back
to Fruit tearing so I've always gone
back and forth I mean my career in Tech
took me all over this world and I've
loved it because travel is my literal
favorite thing to do
and it's tough to go over these
different countries and just ask for
fruit you know you're also doing your
best to to you know be with clients and
such so you kind of have to go outside
that diet so it was a little bit harder
for me to hold on to that um I was a
fruititarian when I visited Nepal and
going back to you know proper structure
you know uh posture of pooping there's
only holes in the ground so you get
really comfortable with that the Eastern
World they figured it out they are the
best poopers in the world I'll tell you
this you wouldn't have to have a certain
posture if you ate properly because it
just slides right out
interesting but when we get in the
starches again with all you know beans
beans and rice talk about being in India
with beans and rice all the time Indian
food's my favorite food on Earth so
another reason why I can't just ever
stick to that but that's balance
uh when I was a fruitatarian you can get
to the point and I did where I had so
much energy I didn't know what to do
with it I was working out twice a day I
could do I could do 10 of these if I had
you know the the time to do it
I had to bring myself a little bit down
from that and so I introduced salads and
salads have put me straight to sleep so
I built my digestion in such a way where
all I was doing was I was energized all
the time and I was I looked the greatest
I felt the greatest I had zero pain zero
inflammation uh going back to the
inflammation factor of what ages you
right because it's just acids breaking
down uh cells
but I realized also too I don't
necessarily want to live that way all
the time sure is it great yeah but I
also want to go explore and have fun so
I built myself away from that salads
that went into you know starches and
stuff like that
um I did eat meat I tried it again for
the first time in five years what
happened
um that wasn't a fun
couple days for me I I got the blowback
from it but I'll say that I could tell
the minute it went into my system it was
a different High it like I said the
steroids the adrenaline and I realized
that wow
um we most of us are who eat meat if you
do are living off that high you're not
actually craving the meat you're craving
the high from the adrenaline and the
steroids right so that's a confession in
2016 for five months I uh tried the
vegetarian thing because I it was more
of like I wanted to like experiment and
see what everyone was talking about
um and it got kicked off because I went
to India for two weeks at the end of
2015. and for those who haven't gone to
India or there's a number of countries
kind of in Southeast Asia that are very
similar is if you go into like a
McDonald's there's literally a veg and
non-vege menu right so it's fully
ingrained in society a lot of it has to
do with religion cultural norm terms uh
history all these different things but
like it is very very serious in terms of
there's a vegetarian menu and a
non-vegetarian menu
um and so while I was there like I was
like that's interesting like I wonder
how they live every day like I'll just
not eat meat okay fine uh there's three
takeaways that I had
the first I lost like 30 pounds
to the point where people would like see
me and they'd be like yo are you okay
like are you like yeah on drugs are you
like are you something or do you have
cancer like literally people were like
worried about me and I was like no like
I'm fine uh but I did lose 30 pounds the
second thing and this sounds very weird
is uh I explained it to somebody as like
I felt like uh
uh I was lighter obviously because the
weight but also
um the blood flowing through my body
felt cleaner which is like a very weird
uh thing to describe to people some
people like that sounds insane but it
just felt like uh I was kind of like
cleaned out a little bit which actually
felt very good uh but the third thing
was it was very hard to operate I would
go out to eat I just for whatever reason
uh friends family my lifestyle like all
these things it was just difficult and
so I broke it five months in uh I
basically was like all right this was
cool experiment but like I'm done and I
had I don't know if you know Bojangles
yeah uh I had it twice in about uh 24
hours
I didn't have a huge blowback but I was
like man I'm gonna live my life and
enjoy the [__] out of this stuff because
it did taste 100x better than I
remembered after not having meat for
like five months and so I took that as
is my body telling me no actually eat
more of this because like you like it or
is it more of like a sugar or dessert
and it's like no this just tastes good
and like it's horrible for you right and
I just kind of didn't spend enough time
to like really figure it out but it was
a fascinating experiment
it just wasn't something that was
sustainable right right and so then when
I saw the longevity research
um I also there's a island I think off
of Greece uh it's like the Blue Zone
where people live uh the longest
historically uh most people live to the
over the age of 100 and they pretty much
eat Mediterranean diets they drink wine
and they get together every single night
there's like a social component to it
and it's like those three things seem to
be what leads to the longest life like
Mediterranean diet is like pretty much
fruits vegetables a little bit of meat
uh but more fish type stuff and uh they
seem to be doing all right
because I have zero resistance around it
this is going back to where I say that
there's chemistry and physics that we
can look at clearly in the body and I
look at eyes
But ultimately these cultures have zero
resistance around that food when they
put it in their bodies they're happy
they're balanced it's a it's a social
component it's love it's not I'm eating
this because I want this outcome I'm I'm
eating this because I should eat this or
I'm feeling guilty they have no
resistance and that is
Betty White I I sometimes have my
moments of mourning why I never got to
get her eyes this is a woman who
lived I think chose to not live past 99
I mean we know she could have kept going
she was gonna live for forever
this is a woman who would eat hot dogs
and chase him with vodka
I just had to Google who Betty White was
that sounds real dumb but yeah I had to
sorry I gotta go
all the time we have for today
I heard the Golden Girls The Golden
Girls yeah I don't know who the
actresses are oh come on man there's
three of them right
[Laughter]
I live in reality so yeah but buddy I
mean this woman is just she was why did
she live this long you know if you ask
someone so she was like the Warren
Buffett of diets
but why she was the most positive happy
loving giving individual I think we've
seen in Hollywood one of the most and we
mourn her passing mainly because if
that's who she was but if you go to a
purist site of this whole detox thing
and say well you know she was eating hot
dogs and chasing it with vodka they'd be
like oh you're gonna die that's it
that's that's it for you good luck you
know you're gonna feel like crap but she
didn't she loved her life she lived in
99 and I think she chose to be like haha
jokes on you I'm out I'm gonna go be
with my man
this is why it always comes down to what
is your relationship with that and
ultimately
if you come to me and saying I'm having
all these ailments and I want to feel
better yes of course we understand you
can go down the proper chemistry and
physics way of cellular regenerative
detox and cleanse the system and get all
these systems back and going
but if you don't experiencing anything
and you're still having a great time and
you're enjoying your life like a Warren
Buffett God bless you I'm never gonna
sit that man down tell him don't eat
that oh I would do that if I saw him for
sure
there's a whole nother thing of uh with
Buffett um what's fascinating is look
he's by far one of the best if not the
best investors of our lifetime at the
same time he has profited off of a lot
of things that probably didn't do so hot
for uh Society right right in terms of
uh Coca-Cola uh Sees Candy uh even some
of the bank stuff so it's a weird thing
where like I actually think he believes
what he says because he's McDonald's
every day he drinks Coca-Cola like hey
it worked for him right uh but I do
think that uh for many other people it
doesn't so it's a kind of a catch-22 all
right so this detox thing let's say that
I go home today and I'm like all right
I'm gonna try this and I'm only gonna
eat fruits berries uh melons Etc what's
gonna happen to my body uh
you'll just start hopefully depending
like I said this is why I love the eyes
let's take a look and see how well your
systems are up and going
um ultimately you're going to start one
craving
right that's the other thing is we're
most of our diets have a lot of sodium
Savory we like that it's satiating
you're gonna be hungry
but the great thing is is give it a week
or so and you're eating this you're
going to have your cognitive dissonance
why the [__] am I doing this
what the hell it's good it tastes good
it's fruit it's fresh you know juice it
eat it whatever it's like a light fast
almost yeah like you're fasting but you
get it you get a cheat which is so funny
because if you consider that the fast
when that's really just our our
biologically correct diet but you're
gonna start craving for sure right
um if you just go like let's say you go
30 day grapes or let's just say you
start on grapes 30 days grapes only
um so is that a real thing so if I get
someone who says I have um
I don't like obviously I love grapes
because I need that [__] for one two
days I don't say the copyrighted c word
um but if if I have someone that comes
to me with a stage three four five
I'm putting them on 30 days of grapes
and it works almost every single time
what almost 100 okay so let's just say I
spend 30 days only eating Justice what
kind of grapes am I eating right Concord
preferably the darker the darker the
better they're more aggressive so
concord grapes yeah it'll kick your ass
and what happens to your body if you
just eat red grapes for 30 days so
it will one Focus just on that chemistry
so anytime you want the body to have
rapid results give it the simplest job
to do give it fast burning uh energetics
right which is fruit
which is the most optimal for the body
it will start to focus on hydration
which you'll get from the fruit but
putting out the waste so it'll kick up
the kidneys it'll Electrify the nervous
system it'll get everything rocking and
rolling and then you'll start to dump
that waste out every single time no fail
it is one of the greatest ways to go and
just rapidly but it'll kick your ass why
do it for 30 days and not like seven or
two you could but I again what's the
intention right if it's some of my
clients who are coming in in a really
really bad they're in chronic states of
just constant pain or again we're
looking at stage five whatever
um then they really want to rapidly get
at this and some of these individuals if
we're looking at a chronic state their
systems are down anyways so the best
thing to do is I could either fast them
we're talking like water fasting to pop
their kidneys open so it'll start to
filter and enter and get the nervous
system going but I always say at least
you know take some some fruit to start
cleansing because it's astringent it's
pulling it'll start pulling the the
mucoid plaque get rid of the
malabsorption so I've I've seen people
who've done 30 days of grapes I've done
two weeks I kicked my butt but I'm
fairly healthy individual hasn't eaten a
lot of the the stuff
and I prep my body before it but I see
people who come out with
I mean
they've passed tumors they've go back in
for the test they don't test positive
anymore I'm lethal with a computer in
front of me and so my quick Googling uh
sleuthing uh pulled up that a lot of or
not maybe not a lot but some doctors are
studying the effect of taking grape
extract yes and what the impact would be
on various cancers in the body yeah what
is the difference between like I go to
the grocery store and I buy grapes let's
say that these red Concordia grapes
sounds super special yeah and I just eat
them versus this like grape extract
which I'm assuming is just like a really
really intense you know component of the
grace what is the difference in my body
yeah so I mean you look at our fruit
today is pretty is pretty sad
unfortunately I mean we haven't we
haven't given the the land rest the
nutrients aren't as there we'd Rush the
process you know even organic we're
still rushing that process the other
thing is we're starting to get grapes
without seeds why seedless grapes well
seeds are the most powerful part of the
grape if you you think about it that's
where they're getting hopefully that's
where they're getting the extract but if
I get with someone I I would hope to see
if we could find seeded grapes but they
started to take those seeds out because
they were so powerful because people
were detoxing but they were saying it's
poisonous
so literally uh on Wikipedia again uh
Wikipedia take it leave it as a source
it says great therapy or grape Diet also
known as oh boy uh ampolo therapy yeah
is a diet that involves heavy
consumption of grapes including seeds
and parts of the vine including leaves
that is a form of alternative medicine
uh then it says the concept was
developed in the 19th century Germany in
spas two names I can't pronounce and
then it said this is an important part
the concept has no scientific basis and
is regarded as quackery by scientific
institutions like the American Cancer
Society I never seen the word quackery
before it's my favorite
what do they mean that it is considered
quackery by scientific institutions like
a snake oil salesman type thing uh
yeah it basically says quackery is often
synonymous with health fraud it's the
promotion of fraudulent or ignorant
medical practices a quack is a
fraudulent or ignorant Pretender to
Medical skill or a person who pretends
uh around credentials that uh do not
actually work yeah yeah so what like
what what is the let's just say there's
two schools of thought right uh there's
one side which is like the American
Cancer Society that's yelling screaming
like quackery quackery whatever that
word means and then there's this other
side that's like no this actually is
helping people like where is the
difference of understanding great greed
oh interesting okay hands down every day
and unfortunately I'm not saying greed
is the problem it comes down to we've
man's gotten too lost in his
Consciousness where there's just so much
lack right
there's a Hippocratic Oath Do no harm
I have a really hard time when you swear
to that oath
and yet there's harm being done to
people I'm not saying that doctor is
harming someone there's a whole there's
just the theories that they go off of I
mean you look at chemotherapy it is 1.5
pH acid
you don't fight a fire with a fire what
caused those cells or rather you know
want to use the word cancer but train
not to use it just because it's owned a
little bit but
if you look at the root of cancer it's
simply cells that have been chewed up by
acids
interstitial acidosis it's just rampant
they're out it's just location location
so why would you go in an acidic state
which those cells are already chewed up
by acid and then go pour in even hotter
acid
that for common sense doesn't doesn't
compute so for me I sit back and say I
always got to follow the money
you're going to follow that money
straight to the American Cancer Society
straight into chemo and straight in the
pockets of every single one of those
individuals who are benefiting and they
could care less whether that person can
walk or not or get out of that room or
live past three months
uh you could call this stuff quackery
but I'll tell you what it works
so that's the only thing is I always say
what is the what's the uh
what does it produce and what is the
result so Steve Jobs is like the example
I immediately jumped to mine right so
um he ate fruits and vegetables almost
exclusively uh and one of the things
people may or may not know about jobs is
that he would actually go on like pretty
uh lengthy fast and uh whether it's true
or not the way that the story is told is
like as a kid he realized that by
fasting he could get to a euphoric State
yeah and it was almost like a drug to
him so he basically would like do these
fast and try to get to this euphoric
State
um but I think the reason why the diet
became so well known other than just
it's a peculiar thing for a guy who who
ended up building Apple
um but when he got diagnosed with uh um
I think it was pancreatic uh cancer yeah
he basically took all the fruits out and
was just like I'm just gonna go like
heavy vegetarian uh or maybe he kept the
fruits in or whatever but no you're yeah
you're right he like doubled and tripled
down on it and uh there was a bunch of
people who were like this is a good idea
especially who were like it isn't a good
idea
in my read on these situations is always
like there's no counter example like
like you don't know if he had done
something else right how long he would
have lived or not lived or whatever but
like how do you look at people like a
Steve Jobs who's known around the world
and when they pursue this stuff is that
like a net positive is it a negative
like how do you look at those type of
situations for this view of the world
yeah Steve Jobs is a great example
um I always find it interesting how most
people never even knew what that diet
was prior to hearing like a fruititarian
so unfortunately we you know Humanity
will use our minds as able the first
ever exposure we have of this is a
negative connotation because he ended up
dying therefore fruitarian equals bad
right and I think the guy who even
played uh Steve Jobs in the movie said
that he went for to Terry and got
pancreatic cancer which made me laugh
because fruits and berries and melons
will never ever produce
cancerous or rather won't acids don't
chew up those cells to then be called
what's cancer
the the the issue is you can go on all
fruits berries melons and go be a
vegetarian or fruititarian
but if you look at Steve Jobs just
looking at him the man was malabsorbed
he was not filtering and so there's
there's always going to come into the
place where this is where ironology will
fit I don't care if you go any One
Direction but get a look at where you
are to start with are you strong enough
to do this we got to fix the systems
that are down first they didn't do that
this he's went on all fruitarian because
I'm sure you read the books and that's
great but you've got to get the systems
working if not you'll have a blowback if
you aren't filtering through your
kidneys no matter what you put in your
body it won't work how do you change
that like let's say that somebody's not
doing it how do you make them filter
through the kidney uh usually it's
through like I said going on a you know
working with someone like myself
um who understands those systems and
then using the right proper herbs and
fruits berries and melons you could do
the 30 days of grapes or 30 days of
watermelon and probably fix that
malabsorption 30 days of watermelon too
oh yeah wow what are the herbs you keep
mentioning sure so I know nothing about
herbs
Street herbs so there's tons out there
right I mean you go into Whole Foods or
whatever and just this whole wall of
herbs and you don't know what the hell
they are which most people don't and
there's singles there's synergistic ones
um most of that stuff is not crafted
well in my opinion a lot of it's
chemicals and so I I steer away from
those type of things I've tried a bunch
I've I mean I've neutralite Amway girl
growing up shackly I've tried them all
and the only thing I know is I I've
moved away from all the ones that I can
find pretty much in the store and I use
really for the most part my mentors so
Dr Morse he is a master herbologist he
knows how to bring these certain herbs
that work with certain parts of the body
and that just comes from knowledge and
so and then he Blends them because again
the body like synergistic chemistry it
doesn't like Elemental so magnesium
copper doesn't like those singles
um and when he Blends them like is he
giving it to you like in a yeah tea bag
or is it like something you sprinkle on
your food like what is like so a few
different ways and and it's great
because you can do tincture all right so
that's whether you use glycerin or you
can do a base dep
ending so we'll do the glycerin base uh
tinctures and then you'll have capsule
form and then you can do tea form but
again some of those herbs don't don't
transfer into certain one of those
modalities and so sometimes they could
just come in a tincture they'd just come
in a capsule
um but they they are the they're like
targets like missiles so you can go on
all fruit and that's great but it takes
longer to really pinpoint those issues
and then you gotta obviously know if
you're making progress or not I always
tell people if you don't see cloudy
urine
cloudy you're in trouble because you
want your urine to look like a snow and
I know I I can't wait to see some of the
comments
what a job she's going to kill people
What is cloudy urine so
I always tell you what urine is
so you know what snowball when you shake
it yeah
one of the best things you could see is
your urine looked just like that
interesting because I was like fully
clear like it's water or you don't want
that and you don't want it to be Brown
yeah yeah dehydrated yeah we don't
definitely want like you know red or
anything like that you know right to
detox symptom but it's fine it's
temporary hopefully uh you want cloudy
you want so I my clients pee in a mason
jar
and I know it sounds whack job trust me
like I said I dude at the doctor when
they gotta touch your period right then
you leave it there you give it a second
it's actually not as nice as a mason jar
but yeah I know well so yeah I mean yeah
it's it's it's cool but it's also weird
because I tell my clients just pee in a
mason jar set it up on the counter and
give it a second you want to leave it
there just
you know but you want sediment
because again what does the body do
every single cell eats and poops
but if you are not getting out that
waste where is it going
storing in the tissues right that's
acids
you need that stuff out you need that
waste out it's mucus it's proteins it's
at so you know it's just cellular trash
that you need out of the system so
if you're not filtering you're gonna
you're gonna blow back every single time
and that's what happened to Steve they
weren't focused because they didn't know
they didn't get it they didn't
understand the four systems of you know
a digestion absorption utilization
elimination if you don't have those four
systems up you're [__] and it's sad we
we got we lost a really good man a
genius because you can't just take that
all the way home you can't just go zero
to 60. you got to know the whole picture
and that's part of why I love iridology
the most like I nerd out on ironology
so hard because that's the basis that's
the road map like hey you can go this
way or this way
you can go allopathic you can go natural
but if I get someone and I can see
they're cellularly not strong they're
probably not going to get through a
round of chemo my grandpa didn't
that man ate like crap he had two
quadruple bypasses that guy was supposed
to die so long ago they gave him one hit
of Chemo when he was gone
and it just shows you you just gotta
check and see where the state of that
body is where they are and what they can
handle and you can tell that through the
eye so I never tell people like let's
get the eye and then I'll basically tell
you go on your own Journey I'll tell you
all day long here's a natural way to do
it but if you're like I'm a
pharmaceutical person God bless you at
least you have the knowledge of where
you are
in the as far as the systems are
concerned so you have the iridology
component where you take the picture of
the eye uh there's also this idea of
like cell regeneration uh that you spend
a lot of time on what exactly is that
sure so obviously all the tissues in the
body uh so we're made up of cells and
two fluids blood lymphatic uh liquid and
then of course your cells
so everything else is just the tissues
and the tissues can regenerate I mean
we've seen thyroids grow back after
they've been radiated but you got to do
of course the right the right protocol
to get that going
um but it really comes down to giving
the body what it needs in order to
regenerate cells
uh when you look at an eye and you see a
really dark patch or what looks like
kind of we call them Crips or lacunas
and they're like these little closed up
little
uh circles or diamond shapes
um and they're black that tissue is
pretty much in the deterioration chronic
deterioration phase or almost gone right
um You can rebuild that and we'll see
that over time in the eye you'll see the
healing lines behind it and those
tissues start to regrow but that's what
we're talking about is really taking
those uh tissues that have been just
eaten up by acids and the lymphatic
congestion that just sits on that you
get the sulfur you get drug deposits
just eating away at that tissue and that
tissue is now compromised completely we
can start to see the Regeneration of
that tissue you know if you're removing
part of the liver we've seen those parts
of the liver grow back you just got to
give it the right
you know chemistry and physics to work
on yeah and so how much of this is like
internal the body to external and I
think about uh longevity is one piece uh
there's a lot of people who are obsessed
with their diet for cosmetic reasons
right they want to have less wrinkles
they want to look younger they want
different skin color they want to uh
change uh the clarity of the eyeball
like there's all these things that
happen and then you start to layer in
things like um you know there's a lot of
science that's coming out and books
around uh breathing and the ability to
get oxygen into your body and how if you
breathe a certain way mainly not through
the mouth but through the nose you can
actually change the structure of your
face and like it just seems like there's
like this spider web and people are like
going out and they're like holy [__]
like actually how we treat our body
determines how we look yeah um is that
all part of like the cell regeneration
it's just being done in different ways
between Diet breath uh exercise sunlight
whatever yeah it's it's huge it's all of
it right I mean again we're there's
there's no within without the and so
forth right so everything you do inside
is I would say more important if you're
looking at physicality and looks right
because the skin is the third kidney so
it's going to respond to everything you
put inside it and the state of what's
going on inside uh is there some Merit
to all the breathing absolutely because
again you have to be able to move that
that the lungs make sure they're filled
make sure they're exercised get out in
nature get out in the in the good
energetics so there's all these other
factors that like I said you could you
could just do the detox or rather the
diet and some of the herbs but there's
other factors as well what you put on
your skin matters you know that's why we
see all these products eventually move
away from the chemicals and into the
natural because this is your third
kidney if this is your only way to
filter out until you get your kidneys
filtering and you're just slamming this
with chemicals it's just going to break
down that third kidney so there's
there's all these different aspects and
that's why the holistic approach is
always better it's not one thing that's
going to solve all the problems in the
world
go out there ground yourself get in salt
water you know relax if you're in a
detox phase don't go hit in the gym go
relax rest make sure that your mind fill
yourself with good information go out
there laugh you know have a great time
there's so much about we're energetic
beings
that we have to also feel outside of it
because like I said you can have these
individuals that are just eating like
crap but their mentality is so great and
I say eating like crap in the sense of
the detox side of it but they're they're
just doing so great they're so they're
surrounded by great people great music
they have no resistance and ultimately
they're dis-ease-free and so
is that the goal is to be disease free
I the goal is to enjoy life it really is
I I want nothing more than for someone
to find joy and then go give joy I would
love to in my mission is to help
everyone be happy healthy and filled
with vitality and then go give as if we
could create that cycle
we live the best lives ever but our joy
it's really Joy is our purpose
but it's hard to find Joy when you're in
constant pain and that's where I tell
people my people usually find me I don't
have to go out there advertise to the
I've got all these amazing mentors
you're like we could blow this up
[__] billionaires I'm like yeah
but my people find me when they're ready
and that's usually where it is is let's
just educate let's tell people there is
a way to be Vitality filled and joyful
and feel really good and there's ways to
to do that
just they'll you know I'll show up when
you're ready or you'll find me when
you're ready but that's the goal is just
to be happy and that's I think when we
feel better
as far as physically we're a lot more
joyful it's hard to be joyful when
you're riddled in pain but if you can
find joy
whilst in the state of pain that's the
ultimate
can you tell other things by taking a
picture of the eye in terms of like
somebody if they work out or not or like
their mental health things that I would
associate with health but may not be uh
just simply like the the classic like
physical health yeah I think that's one
of my favorite Parts about iridology and
uh it took you know after years of
studying this I didn't realize some of
the non-physical parts of this but I
find them to be extremely important so I
love that you bring this up uh you know
there's Shockers if you've ever heard of
those energy centers within the body no
what are those so uh there's you know
yoga yogis or like Vibes like body Vibes
yeah exactly that kind of thing you have
like the throat chakra and you've got
the crown chakra and those are wonderful
energy centers that you can work with in
the body that once they're all according
to certain philosophies once they're all
spinning in the right direction they're
clear and they're wonderful you just
have this perfect alignment right within
yourself I've always thought this is
complete [__] and then I've talked
to people who go yeah and they swear by
it yeah
and I think I've changed my mind on it
actually which is
um it's kind of like uh people will say
oh uh that thing
doesn't actually do what you say it does
right so like the classic example is um
uh there's a movie uh the greatest
showman yes yeah I'm sorry PT Barnum and
uh in it
um there's a scene where there's a
reporter who's been basically he
actually coins the term circus according
to the movie and he's basically writing
all these hit pieces all the stuff and
uh he says to PT Barnum you know hey
don't you feel like you basically are
tricking all these people everything
you're saying here that is not the
fattest man in the world that is not
this that is not that whatever and he
goes you are a Salesman with basically
delivering no value and he says do you
see all the smiles he goes I'm
delivering entertainment and he goes uh
by the way you know basically I don't
think anyone actually thinks that's the
fattest man in the world like but they
enjoy the entertainment and he flips it
and he says uh but you are supposed to
be a theater uh critic but you can't
enjoy theater like who's the fraud here
yeah and
it's weird because like definitely
that's not the fastest man in the world
like like objectively like that is a
quote lie right
um and PT Barnum is who he is and create
the circus like all the stuff but if you
look at through the entertainment lens
it's like okay cool like there's value
because people are smiling and laughing
having a good time whatever if you look
at it from like a scientific standpoint
or a factual standpoint like that is not
a woman with a mermaid tail right it
doesn't cost you
um and so when I think about a lot of
these people who have gone to whether
it's the yogi stuff or others
I always wonder how much of it is like
what they are claiming is the value
right so your body is in full alignment
or whatever or like no actually that
person feels much better because they
went somewhere without their phone for
like a weekend and they came back and
they're a happier person and in some way
like they obtained a closer state to
what they were trying to obtain
regardless of whether it was like some
weird pose that they held for 30 minutes
or like they just got away from their
friends family and phone and like
they're in a better mental state like
it's this weird thing right where like
how are you evaluating it and I don't
have the answers like that's another key
part of it is it kind of just like hey
does that person think it's valuable
then like I guess they think it's
valuable like who am I to judge them
right right no I think that's I think
that's the best point and it's it's
taken me a little bit to get there so I
studied uh chronic healing or Prana
right life what is that chronic healing
uh have you ever heard Reiki reiki's
just the the transfer of healing energy
according to if if this is something one
subscribes to or not
transfer Reiki healing is usually laying
on the hands some don't they don't touch
the person but they transfer uh healing
energy from hands to certain parts of
the body and usually chakras are one of
those targets because it sounds like
magic it's right it's fantastic so I was
like oh what's the Power Rangers it's
amazing right it was like when I was a
kid I was like some Harry Potter [__]
and I'm a big fan of Harry Potter's I'm
gonna go try this out so I actually
studied with uh masterco who now you
might see him with Tony Robbins so he is
a an amazing
um
I would say philosopher Healer Mind
heart he just really is a great
spiritual leader I want to go and
studied chronic healing Underneath Him
in uh San Diego when I lived in Southern
California
San Diego or the no it's not
particularly it was great
um I I wanted to understand how much to
your point is
it what I'm doing or is it the receiving
right and how much credit and Merit does
this stuff really have now I'm an
individual who grew up in I would say a
religious household I don't subscribe to
any religion but the fact that I was
taught to believe in something I
couldn't see like the wind can't [__]
see the wind but we sure do see the
effects of it right and so I wanted to
understand that so I went studied with
him and I would work on people I would
do exactly as masterco said and I could
feel that I was doing something but how
much of that was reality and how much
was it just what I was believing
and whether and that person on the other
side as I was working on them would just
burst out in tears and I would just be
moving my hands like if you were just
watching as a fly on the wall you'd be
like these people would bunch of whack
jobs right you got this person on their
floor crying and this person's waving
their hand over them and
moving energy if we were to look at
something from an ethereal realm right
we would probably see that energy moving
but how much was it this person how much
was it me and I sit back and say one I
don't have the answers two was a really
[__] cool experience and I've helped
a lot of people I'd like to believe I
was just a channel to help those people
But ultimately that person needed to be
in alignment with it they needed to be
able to receive it just like anything in
life if you are in the receptive mode
then you're good with it who are we to
say that it didn't work who are we to
say that person doesn't
actually have great results from it if
they were in alignment with him who are
we to tell them that they're not the
smiles right
uh what do they call the placebo pills
or sugar pills you know uh that person
believed it was helping them so was it
the belief that was more powerful or is
it the medication I always think of a
psychologist as well like a therapy has
become very popular this whole idea of
I've seen a bunch of books when I go to
bookstores around like trauma and like
all these things that now have uh kind
of come to the Forefront and if you
really think about uh a lot of therapy
not all of it but a lot of it is like
you go to a room and someone asks you
questions and you just talk right like
and again we're doing it right now we do
it all all day long we talk to people
like whatever
um but it has this like very profound
effect and maybe it's because of the
topic you're talking about maybe the
person asks you really really probing
questions or somehow you feel like you
should be honest with them or what are
all the things that people claim uh make
it work but it is like a very weird
thing because you could send two people
to the same therapist ask the same
questions and one person walks out and
it's like that was amazing and the other
person like that person is full of [__]
right and I I think
it's like a weird issue because
it's very polarizing as well the person
who goes and it feels like it was
effective they'll defend it basically to
the death yeah what are you talking
about that's not [__] like look what
they did they made my life amazing and
this other person is like no literally I
went and saw the same person like
they're an idiot right look they wasted
an hour of my time and like they should
give me a refund and
I wonder how much of it is just like a
fit this person actually can benefit
from therapy sit talk whatever to
um in the military uh uh there's a
couple of guys who I started to
popularize this idea like a 20 minute
walk it's like a mental health thing
yeah and like it could be therapeutic to
just go for a walk for 20 minutes right
and so when you you see those two things
you're like well maybe they're actually
getting at the same end result which is
this therapeutic you know kind of
solution some people need to talk some
people need to walk
who are you right right I mean it comes
down to believing believing a scene as
opposed to the other way around yeah um
ultimately not one thing is going to
work for everybody
you have that's why we that's what I
love about this world is that we can
find so many different modalities and
and people dive into them and they just
love them and they swear by them and
that's fantastic but that's not to say
that's the only way this other way that
speaks more into this person's listening
is going to be who are we to say what is
truth and what's not
it's that person and what they're
benefiting from it now there's going to
be obviously the other side of things
that we believe that okay that hurting
hurting people is no way no don't do
that I don't see how you can get really
any benefit from that so there's some
certain lines that I draw and say I can
sit right here and say that's not a good
thing right
um huge against you know sex trafficking
and human trafficking stuff like that so
I can consider and be like nope don't
like it there's not a single thing you
could do to convince me that this is
good but there are people out there who
find it beneficial and who find good
it's very tough and I think that
ultimately you have to go with what
works for you and if you're starting to
bash other people then you're getting
out of that alignment so it's basically
like almost kind of like a free speech
thing right where it's like most people
uh I think the line that they draw is
like our country's built on Free Speech
uh but there are certain things that you
cannot do like uh incite violence in
certain situations uh yell fire in the
theater right there's like some very
specific things that uh courts of law
have determined hey this is out of
bounds and your thought process I'll
paraphrase and correct if I'm wrong is
like people should be allowed to do what
they want to do and what they find
happiness in within the bounds of like
the legal system or whatever yeah I mean
obviously you're not gonna really get
anywhere if you're constantly breaking
the law and there are people who have
again how is it that they actually got
there by breaking the law and it's it
comes down to that person's ultimately I
can't tell you what that person's karma
is what it took them to get here and I
can't certainly judge it it is not my
place so I always tell people approach
everything with compassion you do not
know how this person you know every
single client that comes to me I don't
know how they got here I'm gonna sit
here and say well you do realize that
you manifested your own reality and
you've basically made your own hell it's
the last [__] thing they want to hear
it's not going to help them I'm there's
no way I'm going to say that I will
however approach every single
conversation with compassion because I
have zero clue where your alignment is
and where your karma is and what it is
that you want for your life truly no one
can guess what that is for someone and
when we try
I I just I don't think it results in
anything that great do you know who Kane
Velazquez is
if I if I said to you
um I saw an individual shoot and try to
kill someone is that a good thing or a
bad thing depends on the situation okay
most people would say it's a bad thing
Kane Velasquez uh was arrested for
attempted murder 10 gun charges uh and I
want to make sure I don't get this wrong
but uh he basically chased down a man uh
this guy Harry uh gurate uh in a vehicle
and shot at him tried to kill him and uh
the reason was because this man is
accused of has been arrested and charged
with
sexually assaulting a young relative of
Cain Velasquez now without that context
chasing someone down in a vehicle and
shooting at them and trying to kill them
most people say is bad when Kane
Velasquez was arrested the internet
erupted and said free him
and it was this fascinating thing he's
out on bail now right and so it's going
through the legal system but you have
this like Court of public opinion which
is very biased because it is the court
of public opinion and there's tons of
fight fans and all this stuff right so
he was a well-known uh person who
basically said I understand the
boundaries of law
but the context in which this guy was
retaliating is actually okay in my
ethical View
on this flip side there's a lot of other
people who were like nope doesn't matter
what the situation was like you
shouldn't black and white try to gun
people down right in the streets yeah
but it did introduce a lot of complexity
a lot of context a lot of Ethics a lot
of uh compassion versus not uh who
should be the Arbiter of Truth who
should be the Arbiter of punishment like
it brought in all these weird things it
was fascinating to watch
um
because it was playing out online
because it was somebody that people knew
right and I always think of that example
specifically because
it's an extreme example
and it probably touches on two extreme
things sexual assault of a young person
and then trying to murder them right
what would the response have been if he
just went to a bar and just beat him up
right I don't even know if he gets
arrested frankly right like I think that
there could be cops who literally show
up and say what happened oh have a good
day right attempted murder is a
different story also if uh that
individual had simply robbed a young
relative
maybe the reaction is different than
obviously sexual assault being such a uh
emotion-packed like just most people
look at it as like a complete violation
of the ethical framework that they have
and so I don't know what the answers to
these things are but as you unpack them
there's this complexity that ends up
making things not black and white
that is completely lost on the internet
like it was very much like you were
either on Kane Velasquez side or not and
that was it I and I think that
unfortunately we get again go we get in
too much of the mind we get into our
opinions we get into our ego
I'll go I'll go way further than that is
it took me a while and through the
different mentors and different Spirits
I've studied my whole life to find the
truth that is my goal is to uncover the
truth about everything as much as
possible it's a maddening Journey at
times because I learn a lot of things
that I never wanted to know
But ultimately I can see beyond it I can
see that it's just the journey I truly
when I look at these type of things you
know I
I love first 48. I love I've watched
that [__] all day long and I grew up in
a household you weren't allowed to watch
that because protect yourself from that
stuff but I was always really fascinated
and I got to this point where I realized
everyone has choice in Freedom
it's what we came to this physical form
we wanted to experience this whole
physical game and this journey
but there's a level that we don't see
and it's that Soul connection level that
Soul agreement it's these two
individuals somehow agreed they were
going to teach each other this lesson
this is where this is just a philosophy
that I finally boiled it down to
and it's helped me a lot to look at
things without any bias it's yes of
course murdering someone may not be the
highest choice I am one to encourage
High choices why because you're just
collecting Karma all throughout your
lifetime and you're probably undoing
some karma from a prior lifetime
depending on what you subscribe to as
far as a belief system
but you come into this world and every
single thing you do has a ripple effect
it's what that choice you make that
choice
to collect Karma
in a you know cause and effect way it's
not good or bad
but you're always collecting and I think
that every single time I see these type
of instances those two individuals come
into each other's lives to teach each
other a lesson you look at that Mom they
had the I can't remember
um her her daughter was molested and
murdered by the man she was married to
and
when she and I think it was either the
man she was married to or was it uh just
someone and she went into the courtroom
as he was being sentenced pulled out a
gun and shot him to death
of course she's arrested and everything
and she was like I'm good I'm good I
made my choice I know what I know what
that consequence is and that's all life
is is the freedom of choice and the
consequences that go with that and
ultimately can I sit there and say he
was wrong no because it was right for
him
did he now collect Karma take someone
else now did he Fight Fire with Fire I'm
not the biggest fan of that but who am I
to sit here and tell him that that
wasn't good for him he probably feels a
[__] ton of relief well so does she
you know she felt she was doing right by
her daughter by getting even
you will find different religions who
sit there and talk about that as bad and
good and bad and good and ultimately no
one of us has a single [__] clue that
person's ending up in Hell or not
that's all what they're experiencing
here and that's ultimately their
individual journey and whatever Soul
agreement they had with that person at
that time so that's kind of where I come
in and it's not a popular belief because
no one wants to hear
everyone's just is choosing their own
journey and creating their own path and
their soul connection they decided to
help each other at a different realm
yada yada they want throw the
[__] in jail or you know just
move along and forget that that person
did that to your sister
do you want to know one of the most
famous uh people in the world right now
who has admitted to killing people
it's Prince Harry
I haven't read the book
but I saw I saw the headlines and uh I
saw the snippet and he basically said
that uh he was a helicopter pilot and he
estimated that he killed 25 people yeah
this is a prince whether I don't know
exactly how it works but I think he's on
the outs but he's still a prince or
whatever finger Prince my blood right
yeah can I kick you out of that I don't
know somehow I must still keep calling
him Prince Harry because that's what I
think his name
maybe the uh uh the Royals will come for
me
but it's fascinating because all of a
sudden it was kind of like uh oh the
context was war oh he's Prince Harry oh
it was in a helicopter he didn't look
him in the eyes and you know with a with
a pistol and shoot them like there's all
these aspects to it and like yeah people
were like I probably shouldn't talk
about that but at the same time there's
a lot of people who kind of just like
glossed over her like oh yeah you said
he killed some people
and it again it's just fascinating to
kind of see because I don't know what
the right answer is right I don't know
if you had said to me before there was a
public reaction to it you could see a
world where it's like wow one of our
countrymen went and he defended our
country there's another I was like Wow
you went and how do you know those
people weren't innocent people and and
everything in between
just a weird thing I don't know it is
and and I've I have been I was raised by
a family who every everything was wrong
and we're right
right very and and
unfortunately as a young child growing
up I always bucked that I was like well
why again why why is that person wrong
but this person's okay why is this
person in the Bible who murdered they
were great but this person today was
murdering us it never made sense to me
it was like I said Common Sense this
make it make sense
and it was always well we don't have all
the answers but we're right and I don't
like I just never could get on that
system hero of your own Journey have
your own journey and so you know I grew
up and I had had a lot of judgmental I
mean we were having this conversation
three 40 years ago I would not be at
this Consciousness level that I am now I
would have been probably more on the
judgmental side like no don't ever
[__] need a piece of meat again
unless you want to be yeah just very
hardcore I'm right I'm right a lot of
ego and that's what we see in this world
today as a ton of ego driving all of
these responses all of these beliefs and
how did you get rid of your ego
get your ass kicked enough times
and hand it to you have enough failed
relationships have enough I mean just
um it it took me what really kicked me
in the asses uh breaking my engagement
with my fiance
and being able to look at that and say
I'm only going to focus on what I did on
what did I bring to the table what did I
not do what was I Reaching For What was
the separation on my part basically I
just went and had a great conversation
with Mira every day not a single thing
was their fault so you were engaged to
somebody and you called off the
engagement between engagement and
wedding yeah
and
did you just like wake up one day and
you're like no
mind you we've been in and out for
two and a half years okay
um so and how long were you engaged for
two weeks no a month oh okay so like
it's not like you had been engaged yeah
no and it was very quick it was but
again we had already had our struggles
um I mean well
um easy to say not beat around the bush
drop the bomb so I've never dated a man
in my life I've been only historically
dated women and so my fiance
she and I had gone back and forth Always
a Woman yes
we'll drop more more bombs
um so she and I had been on in and out
and just learning our lessons again this
is how the soul kind of contracts and
agreements I started to learn more about
this as we went through our Journeys I
watched as every single time we do this
breakup and back again and break up and
back again we learned more and more
lessons
and it frustrated us more but it also at
the end gave us more compassion for one
another and we realized just our paths
were going two different ways what was
causing the breakups and then what was
bringing you back together always
childhood issues interesting always
you know like what
um
usually our parents always came down to
it our moms specifically came down to me
it was always getting involved no it's
just how we were raised you know my mom
um you know when I again this is me I
can't even judge her anymore because
she's choosing her own Journey it just
didn't align with that we've never
gotten along we've always butt heads I'm
a very strong individual so is she uh
her you know my my fiance's mom who had
dealt with alcoholism
out of you know as Melissa's in a very
young age and so there was all of this
stuff from our childhoods mainly how we
were raised and our issues with our moms
that caused us to come together and
almost help fix those issues and release
those things because
I I I truly believe that we'll attract
any person
into our existence that will help us
become the better version of ourselves I
really truly think that's the only
reason we get into relationship but
there are just perfect mirrors and
ultimately I realized well I'm
continuing to go down this path of
of being the same person and not
shifting we keep doing this in and out
in and out thing and I'm just blaming
you and you're blaming me and I why did
you guys keep coming back together I
hadn't learned the lesson yet we like
the micro lessons we kept getting and
kept getting closer and kept getting
closer and it was it was fascinating to
me to watch us finally break and how I
knew we learned the lesson is when we
separated because we got engaged again
and then you got engaged again and I
broke it off again so twice twice how
long between the first engagement and
the second breaking it off uh six
six uh five months five months so we
separated for five months yep
dated other people
and then got back together now I how
does that work like you just like uh you
up text or like you write a lot of
humbling emails and basically you own
your [__] okay and I owned all my [__]
got it as I came in not a single thing
did I blame her for and that's what I'm
saying is the best way to get rid of the
ego is just take take inventory and
responsibility for every single thing
that you bring in your life because
that's really all you're doing you're in
relationship with yourself anytime you
get into a relationship with another
person you're just really looking to be
a better individual and so every time we
come together we'd separate both anger
and all this blame and I'm gonna do this
and that's it you know we gotta sell the
condo we're selling it
how I knew we learned the lesson and we
could really finally allow ourselves to
to move forward is when we sat there we
separated and we could still show up in
support and love and we're best friends
really that woman will have I will have
her back forever
because she's a good person
has it been painful as a relationship
absolutely does she always have your
back yes she will yeah yeah absolutely
and that's that's how we knew we learned
that lesson so we no longer feel like oh
we need to be in relation like I need to
I need to have you because it's this oh
oh cool like
hopefully I'll be at your wedding you'll
be at mine yeah this will be great can I
ask a really weird question uh and this
comes from a complete place of ignorance
so I'm looking to learn uh when two
women are in a relationship with each
other and there's an engagement is there
a prior conversation as to who is going
to propose to who because the societal
Norm when it's a man and a woman yeah
like if my wife proposed to me uh a lot
of people have been like that's abnormal
that's like non-traditional right and
again I use the word non-traditional
because it's a tradition right I don't
know that's necessarily A Reason yeah
why but how does it work in a
relationship where there's two women is
there a conversation or how does that
work I I think there was a conversation
um I had she had been married before
okay uh she had you know obviously has
her ex-wife and she's been married
before I had never been married I'd
never been engaged and so for me I think
there was this automatic since I've
never done that you've already been
married like maybe I should ask uh
interesting maybe I should be the one to
do that because I don't know how you'd
feel you've already been down this road
it's brand new so there was this and
frankly it just came down to
she gave in and and did it right so we
were both kind of in this like who does
it so it is a little interesting uh I
almost wonder if it's like uh you know
meet at High Noon and like draw who gets
the ring outfit
if you're lucky you'll find someone who
wants to do that okay there's always
usually one person that's scared to
[__] death and they're not doing it
um and it's it's interesting because I
always find that uh people say Well it
must be easier to be with a woman like
absolutely not is it harder
uh for me I would say yes but again I've
been so I've never dated a man okay why
do you think it's harder
foreign
you are wired very similarly
um I I bucked this for a long time like
I said I've never dated a guy you could
say I was born gay but now I'm at this
point where I'm like okay
that was fun that was awesome now we're
now we're open to guys right it's just
like sudden shift yeah but okay hold on
wait I got a lot of questions yeah I
can't believe we're actually talking
about this uh
the idea of being born gay yeah how do
you think about that because I have
friends uh I'm like very fortunate I
actually think this is probably one of
uh the greatest uh assets maybe that I
have or or like great Fortunes in life
is I have people from literally every
Walk of Life I know people who were
horrendous horrible criminals
to like the next Mother Teresa literally
everywhere in between I know people as
American as they come I know people who
are uh couldn't care less about America
and like they love their country like
whatever yeah and then across uh
religions across sexual orientation like
all these different things and it's
fascinating to kind of see all this
stuff
born gay is probably actually one of the
things that if I pulled all of them they
don't have opinions about yeah because
it's not something that they deal with
on a day-to-day basis it's not something
that is part of like their personal
experience like how do you think about
that hey guys I hope that you're
enjoying this conversation as you
probably realize we don't run any ads on
this show that's right all the other
podcasts all the other YouTube shows
that you watch they have advertisers we
don't have any direct relationships with
advertisers and we simply create this
because we enjoy doing it now that we do
that though we have a team and if you'd
like to support us one way you can do
that is to go subscribe to the pop
letter it's a daily letter that I write
to about 235 000 people about my
personal opinion on financial markets
business technology and Bitcoin just go
to pompletter.com and you can sign up
there I'd love to have you join us and
it's a great easy way to support the
work that the team and I are doing on a
daily basis all right let's get back
into this conversation
so I'm probably less hardcore okay than
a lot of the I'd say gay community is uh
I never thought really hard about that
but I I had a very different experience
with uh my time of you know prescribing
as being gay right
um there are individuals and I would
have said I would never and I'd go to my
grave without ever dating a man because
I just interesting it didn't click
before because you weren't attracted to
them yeah it's just I I love men I mean
they're all over my life and business
and family and I've never had a bad
relationship with one there was no
reason why right era quotes why I didn't
date men except it just didn't register
I just automatically pictured women in
that way and so people would say well
you were born gay
okay but how much of that is a choice
and I fought for a long time with the
fact that I was like okay I'll go out
dancing I'll dance with a guy
nothing was going on nothing was
happening he wished there was but
it's like I'm really sorry about this
nothing's going on would you tell them
oh very upfront okay oh yeah I'm not
like I I you weren't like an Irish exit
you were like sorry this isn't my thing
there's literally nothing happening and
I don't mean to kill your ego with that
but like you're a good that can do but
there's literally nothing Computing and
poor guys what was their reaction
all over the place shocked they they
couldn't believe it and I'm like you
can't take this personal like seriously
don't take this person because there's
some of the most gorgeous individuals
I'm just like you're amazing but they're
just it's just not Computing so not for
me and a really really struggled with
that whole uh saying that
I could actually be open to something
because my spiritual side was struggling
like well why does the physical matter
aren't you connected to the soul aren't
you but I just at that time I was
learning all my lessons through women
only which makes sense like I said you
boil it down to you know mommy issues
and yada yada and I'm not saying I
didn't love these women for who they
were without any issues I'd probably
still without any issues would have been
with them
there are too many there are too many
opinions about the gay community
that I feel we're never going to agree
the gay community is divided the
I hate labels so uh straight communities
divided everyone's going to have their
opinions but that's true of every
Community right true of every community
let them [__] do what they're gonna
do because I sit here today and it's
extremely humbling to sit here and say
I would have said I was born gay and I
would never date men but here I am
first time ever
open to dating men
and it's really really perplexing
because what do you think changed
or do you even consider a change or is
it just ego and going back to that ego
conversation has a lot to do with it ego
uh its main purpose is to protect you
and I had no reason to protect myself
from those relationships
but I think women were probably the only
way I could actually break that
you know because you can really like
just flush things out with women like
they'll just they'll go to town with an
issue
don't question
I have a lot of friends who uh are in a
straight relationship and I uh
understand how they argue because it's
the way that my wife and I argue yes
in your relationship especially when
where you're together you're not
together you're together again
how did arguments go down same way same
there's no difference yeah I mean we
you're still I mean there's not too many
differences you're like you're petty
you're you're a jackass you'll slam the
door you're wrong you're right yeah it's
the same [__] I mean there's really no
difference I don't do any of that by the
way and you're Italian just make sure
that you tell my wife I'm perfect
I can't say I mean there were some women
that drove me to Hulk status and I tell
you what I'm tiny things so but I know
crazy
um there's there's really no difference
when it comes to the women and that's
kind of the things you I started to
realize wow as I'm as I'm seeing this
it's less about the form it's more about
the person it's where do I want to learn
my lessons do I want to learn it with a
female do I want to learn with the men
doesn't matter you're going to do the
same thing ultimately every person is
going to have emotions thoughts beliefs
and you're never going to agree on one
thing I was given some of the best
advice it's like there's always going to
be five or ten non-negotiables in your
relationship and those are things no
matter what you do you'll never see eye
to eye on and you'll never agree upon
be okay with those things and
some people can last through that and
some people like no you know going back
to the diet you have so many people who
are vegetarians who will never date a
meat eater and I'm like why why not
I could I'll cook you bacon right now if
that's what's in alignment with you all
[__] put it on the grill
because it's not mine and why does my
decision affect you but that took that
takes a while and so the arguments are
the same this it's a money sex friends
job it's the same [__] it's no different
at all you know it is um
it's this fascinating idea though that
you now are open to dating men yeah do
you think that's a biological thing a
psychological thing
because I I'm assuming and again I want
to be very careful I don't make too many
assumptions here uh because I literally
uh have no knowledge whatsoever and
you're giving me an education
that people in the gay community are you
an outcast now
I've always been an outcast okay you've
always been an outcast I've always been
an outcast in the game like how is it
how is it viewed in terms of somebody
who dated women their entire life and
now you're like no actually
I'm open to dating men I uh so I guess
we'll find out okay because I've not
I'm not the first time you're saying it
this is one of the first times I'm
saying it so amazing to everybody out
there
um this my ex is gonna be thrilled oh
she doesn't know oh no she knows okay
we've had that conversation because I
would hate for her to find out via a
podcast
um no so we're just the rest of the
world again she's again she's my best
friend you know this would be like hey
Mom she'll be happy about it though what
about her is she open to dating men now
um
I or you don't know I don't know yeah I
don't think I don't even think I asked
that question because I again this comes
down to like the here's my experience
and whatever you offer to me is a gift
and so I think that uh she's a very
conscious individual I mean she's
elevated she's she's through me and
through our relationship she's a totally
different person and it's and in a great
way is she a fruit Italian as well no no
no she actually helped me not be a fruit
Italian for a little bit okay yeah
nobody we had a blast yeah all over the
place drink a fantastic
um now she's leaning towards more and so
we're making her juices
you know again balance
um all right now let's get down to the
serious details if uh
you were previously attracted to women
and now you're open to dating men uh is
that a I'm open to men and women or just
I'm open to dating men uh I've
I think these are great these are great
questions I
I will say I'm not gonna limit myself
okay I'm I'm also not very focused on it
this is another great thing is
through my relationships and learning
these lessons I now feel more
comfortable in my own skin and not
needing anyone before I needed someone I
always needed the relationship I needed
that companionship not that I couldn't
be alone and happy I thrive alone
but there was always this I need this
relationship and I really think it comes
down to that I'm not done learning my
lesson I'm not conscious of what that
lesson is but for some reason I just
need that relationship and I need some
of that uh iron sharpens iron type of
thing and contrast to continue to get
more clarity and now I'm just clear
and so it's not a focus it's not like I
put myself out there I didn't be like
okay go on the datings I'm now open to
men it's not like that it's just simply
getting to that awareness where I'm so
on purpose with everything else that if
someone comes in and they add to my life
fantastic we do this journey together
and have a blast cool
all right my last question is uh have
you gone on dates with men yet I have
not no all right we're gonna do this
again at some point in the future and I
want to hear about the different
experience of going on a date with a
woman versus with a man
oh boy like I've never gone on a date
with a man
okay I've gone on a date with only one
woman my wife
um
and so like because you have or will
have had both experiences like it'd be
fascinating to understand like what are
the similarities what are the
differences yeah and how much of a date
I'll put that in air quotes as to like a
traditional two people going out that
are potentially romantically interested
in each other is a shared experience of
like going on the date together
versus like there are differences
between two women two uh men and then a
man and a woman it's like a fascinating
it'll be fascinating I think there's a
lot to your point I mean Eat Pray Love
right she was married yeah yeah there's
like multiple stories like this and then
she goes to women yeah there's not too
many that have uh been only women and
are going to men so this will be this
will be fascinating anyone who's like a
public figure or well known I don't know
this is this is brand new territory
Clarity and it's it's fascinating I I
love it for a lot of different reasons
mainly because I think I held to that
I'm gay and this is it and I'm only
gonna you know
pick from a pool of ten percent a very
tiny tiny pool uh to choose from it's I
really was holding tight to that and I
held a lot of ego and being an outcast
in the gay community one of them why
were you an outcast uh so I didn't fit
the fit the mold when I'd walk into some
of the clubs in the bars and stuff and
like hey so you're really a straight
girl you look straight
and you're only wanting really good
looking women
you don't want a Butchy type gal so
you're straight you have to be straight
and it was always a constant issue with
me and I'll say and I didn't really I
didn't want to go to the Prides because
I'm not a big partier I enjoyed
different activities and I also again
the question why would come out why are
we having Pride why is there such this
need to
have a huge event and I always looked at
these events with
I I would say a judgmental eye back then
is okay well if this is about being gay
then why aren't we sitting with people
and learning their their stories why do
we've got strippers and and sex toys and
everything there was always this weird
thing for me I couldn't quite grasp and
And subscribe to
and then it got to
well
um
sure okay gay community but but then I'm
also very much a conservative in my you
know political beliefs and and so forth
and so there's just one after the other
as to why I didn't fit into the
community and now you look at the
you look at everything that's happening
in politics with you know the the gay
community and transgender and and
non-binary and all this stuff about the
drag queens and and frankly there's this
part of me that just sits back and goes
everything is shifted slightly
it's no longer Stonewall this is now a
totally different conversation this is
now totally different scenarios that
we're talking about the lgbtq community
and I have no judgment whatsoever again
go out there
do your thing Do no harm obviously right
um but it's it's different for me to to
to sit back and say that my life would
change that much because
most of my friends are are straight most
of the people I've worked with in my
career and and whatnot are straight if
we're using the labels and it's but I I
have a feeling that there's going to be
some sort of blowback from this and this
is part of why I haven't put it out
there I kind of keep some of my personal
life pretty private but I'm sure that
people are out there going well
that's [__] stupid so what now you're
just not gay
why are we also holding the labels why
why aren't we giving freedom of choice
and that's ultimately my my biggest
thing is have freedom and choice and
some people
not a choice totally understand that
I would have said the same thing you
mentioned the pride parade and I
remember reading it just look it up uh
back in 2019 there was this article and
I remember
um
been kind of surprised as to some of the
critiques of the pride parade right this
is I lived in San Francisco at one point
uh it's a huge huge event there in New
York City obviously the same thing the
universities were around the United
States uh and the Articles titled Clash
of values uh why a boycott is brewing
over the pride parade and the main point
was that it had been overrun by
corporate sponsors and that there was
also critiques of like the Deep
politicalization of the pride parade and
it's a fascinating thing because
that's a story across every industry
across all these things it's like oh the
corporates got involved right there was
like the uh uh the greed the government
the capitalism got their like hands into
this thing yeah and
it always just struck me as like I would
have never thought that the pride parade
like that would have been a thing but
then when I started to understand it was
like oh maybe this is like a societal
thing like it's happening in so many
different areas that just like we're
seeing push back in other areas a loss
of trust in institutions and things like
that people are saying hey we actually
don't want the corporate you know kind
of hand in the cookie jar if you will uh
and we just want to have it stand for
what it stands for but like I don't know
if there's like a right answer there
yeah and it's it's actually uh it's
confused me a little bit of watching
over the years and I have that I've been
to San Francisco I've been to New York
so so I've been to them but it was
always in this
I I'm going because I feel like I had to
I was younger right and I'd lived in all
these different cities and tried it out
and So eventually you know the friends
or the person I was dating you know we'd
go but I was always like I'm just gonna
watch and see how this evolves and I
worked for companies who you know uh I
was a flight attendant for a year uh
took a break from technology sales when
in and Alaska Airlines very Pride
forward so anytime the pride parade came
along they had a whole flow they got
dancers and all this stuff everyone's
wearing the the rainbow uh you know part
of the uniform during the pride season I
guess they call it uh I worked for
Amazon on their technology side uh
internally huge I mean you could have
your badge with rainbows and there's
just a Facebook presents Facebook same
way all these big companies
and for me I start to look at some of
these
celebrations as like burning man you
know back in the day Burning Man was a
[__] the man celebration and now it's I
can't say it's lost it's original thing
but you can see if you've ever gone or
you've talked to the people it's
definitely changed from what its
intention was to what it is now now it's
this you got you know famous people
going in there and you know there's lots
of drugs
and take your you know 10 million dollar
RV there and that's great and so some of
those people that have been there
forever hate that but then there's other
people going why can't we experience why
can't we go enjoy this
everything's gonna go through an
evolution and I feel like
you can tell by some of these these
communities where we are consciously and
our thought are we are we cutting off
and we're judgmental and no one is
allowed are we open and now allowing you
know corporations and different people
of different uh uh I'd say you know
orientations you know all these
different types and we continue to go
through these cycles and I think that
we're just going to continue to do that
so though again no right and wrong it's
always just going to continue to evolve
into something
depending on where we are and I feel
like we're in this space where we're
really trying to understand what the
purpose and the origin of these things
are and make sure that we're doing
things in alignment with our values but
how do you do that when you have a bunch
of people in the whole society that have
different values it's really tough to
land on one truth and so now that's why
I think we start to see in this time is
you're getting individuals like myself
who have lived their entire life gay who
would I'm conservative you know I walk
around with a 1776 tattoo I'm I was
raised a patriot I am a patriot that's
not necessarily welcome in the gay
community because it's largely very
liberal and so if I'm conservative I
must be against the gay people and
that's not the truth so I that's very
interesting and it is very true you have
what they call the Log Cabin Republicans
or what what are those well those are
the the gay individuals who subscribe to
being Republican or more the
conservative
I I'm more I would say more on that yeah
libertarian type person because again
freedom and choice
so you said you have a 1776 tattoo I do
and then okay right there on your wrist
yeah and in the gay community that is uh
a little different uh than maybe the
majority from a political standpoint
right did you ever have like
conversations that ever come up yeah
absolutely all the time and for me I
always my goal is to always find Common
Ground as much as possible because I
think we're all I want to believe we're
all after the same thing and that's
Freedom Joy uh love wanting to be a part
of a community and so when you can find
common ground
in any community that you go into that
is sometimes work you need to make sure
you're armed with knowledge you can't
just walk in willy-nilly and saying [__]
and getting in trouble for it because
you know
um but it's that's really it's it's
tougher than one would think and I
strive to find Common Ground no matter
where I am so I can get along with a
bunch of different people and different
communities because I'm not coming in
with I'm [__] right and you're wrong
or classifying an entire group as this
and so going back to kind of the
political beliefs you find some people
saying well if you're gay then you're
liberal because liberals want for gay
freedom and gay rights and yada yada and
transgender rights and so it almost it's
it's this classification that happens
but what about the people who aren't
I'm not going to sit here and tell you
what you can and cannot do again I err
on the side of please don't harm
and please only you know go with age
accountability where that they can make
a choice you know let's not have
children
changing genders because you just never
know when they're going to want to
change their mind or whatnot we see this
all over the place but you're not going
to get me on a pedestal saying well
that's wrong and that's right it's fast
the
transgender and then the like wait I'm
going back I guess there's a lot yeah I
I literally had a friend who was trying
to explain this to me and again I'm so
ignorant I'm almost like scared to even
talk about it because I I I never want
to like offend anyone and have like a
place of ignorance but um the way that
they were describing it is like these
aren't just kids like some of these are
20 something 30 something year olds
right like going back and forth and
it was this thing of just like hey
people are trying to figure out who they
are how they want to live their life you
know like like biologically like all
these different things that it's just
really really hard if you don't go
through like even I'm just talking to
you and I'm like hey so like how do two
women in a relationship argue with each
other I have no clue how that works no
right and you're like uh same way like
you and your wife aren't you everybody
yeah so there's like more similarities
than not I don't know it's just it's
fascinating yeah and that's and that's
why I say we gotta really be careful I
mean there's things that I could have
been really hardcore conviction on five
ten years ago what's the biggest thing
you change your mind on I'm being gay
that's probably the biggest
change around could I swear what about
your money I would have laid my [__]
life down did you ever have a guy try to
convince you that you weren't gay oh God
I feel like that's like a very guy thing
to do this guy yeah okay they're my
favorite and I'll just and I'm not that
because what is like the best story you
have about you interacting with a guy
who's interested in you and you being
like nah dude so uh bar scene obviously
okay
I love this because it it I I eventually
got him down from his mad streak after I
turned him down so rid of our I'm I'm
with my friends I'm with the gal that
I'm dating at the time and I go up to
the bar to get my drink and of course
this gentleman's standing next to me and
you're by yourself I'm by myself oh okay
perfect Target yeah hi and you know to
my defense I look very straight and I've
been I've always dressed very feminine
I've always had my nails and the hair
and all the things and the heels
so I roll up to the bar and I can tell
he's he's checking the scene and I'm
just okay we're going to bartender get
my drink are you trying to ignore him
ignore but like I'm definitely realizing
reading his energy this is what he's
wanting got it any any tops me on the
shoulder and
you know hi and he goes hi and he
introduces himself I got a handshake yes
I'm Matt I saw Mel and he says we're
very beautiful what are you doing you're
now wearing a straight bar
not that that matters because it's again
no labels everyone's welcome wherever
they want and so we're at a place where
it's just mixed and he's so you know
like what do you do in years I'm just
I'm here friends and it's great and
everything's good like you know we just
get to chit chatting and he goes well I
would love to take you out sometime
I was like I said um like as friends or
if or am I I'm assuming this is interest
right like I'm assuming you're
interested in me and he's like yeah in
that fashion usually I'd say like in
what fashion like how do you want to
meet up and he's like because I want to
take you on a date like I want to call
you and take you out a date I said has a
guy ever talked to a girl at a bar
ask them to go to dinner or anything
else and just want to be friends oh only
once I've only had that once and we're
still friends you're the first person
ever in history he's never hit on me
um but and he's in any way so I said
well I said I that is very kind of you
thank you so much I'm very flattered
however I I only exclusively date women
and he's like you're just saying that
because you don't want to go out he's
like you don't have a foot and he's
starting to get a little his Pride's a
little hurt
and he's like you're saying that you
know you girls say you're [__] gay
when they're not because they don't want
to be just [__] tell me you don't
want to date me and I was like hey this
is like he's he's like no you're lying
like you've dated guys like you just
just tell me I said I've never dated man
he's like what do you mean you never
dated a man I said well I haven't never
look I've never defend the whole world
I've never been romantically involved
with the man he's like well that's why
you're gay this is my favorite
that's why you're gay
[Laughter]
you've never met the right one you found
a genius this guy oh man
he's like listen
give me 10 minutes
and now I know I've got a beer in me so
I'm like all right that's all it takes
I'm lightweight so like
oh I think he said five minutes like
five minutes I said five minutes
you're gonna take away
32 years in five minutes my girlfriend
and I go for five hours in the hot tub
what are you gonna do in five minutes
and he looked and I said it loud enough
to the rest of the people in the bar are
just like
oh damn I was like it must be really
[__] god-like with you in five
minutes and he just sunk and now in my
mind we just like melted away
he just he you could just like he got
like an inch shorter and of course you
know at the time I was just you know
full of piss and vinegar and I I could
have been softer that I was trying to
joke you know what I'm saying with a big
old smile on my face but now the whole
bar is kind of looking at him and he's
just like I'm gonna see my way out of
this oh he just
melted crawled away
I mean later on I went over I taught him
on the shoulder I was like dude like I I
am serious I wasn't lying to you but
come hang out with us like yeah you know
don't you're gonna be cool yeah everyone
is cool all right yeah but it was my
favorite I mean that's like a pretty
good story I mean five minutes
foreign
the part that uh to me is fascinating if
I was in your situation or just like it
in a bar where
that isn't like the first thought
probably for a guy like that and then
you kind of have like the upper hand
because you're like you're like waiting
to pull out like the like the Ace in
your back pocket right yeah
like I feel like he kind of got what he
deserved yeah I mean he was a little now
this guy's gonna like literally like
leave a comment and be like hey man that
was me [__]
still single I'm kidding
totally kidding he said five minutes or
five years
give me five more years and we'll be
good uh no it's it is it's a trip
um I will say that's why I said is I've
never I never want to sit here and say
this is definite I always understand
that we always we have this journey and
ultimately we just want to experience as
much as possible my things just don't do
don't do harm yeah right and I I want to
see people enjoy their life and if this
is something I can bring to the table
and ironology is [__] cool and it's
great and it for me it's a window into
someone because the conversations you
and I are having are elevated they're
about pretty much everything that's
going on people are going to be very mad
that we had this conversation there's
gonna be a lot of things too far
uh throw an idea at you which is uh
you're the type of person I would call a
mental blender
you probably never heard this term
before no I've not I love it when people
hear your story and hear you talk their
minds will go into a blunder because
they can't compute it's like literally
like a heart like a overheating of their
brains and smoke may come out of their
fingers because they're like wait a
second there is it somebody who is a
conservative
gay who now has decided maybe they're
not gay who also has had a career in
Tech a lot of people don't like tech
industry uh but also is interested in
iridology and also is able to articulate
how they think feel act in a way that
usually most people can't
and then also
is non-judgmental of other people like
when you add all that up it's like wait
I thought that like conservatives were
supposed to do this or liberals supposed
to do this or I thought gays this or or
straight people like
you put that in and it's like how many
people if you if you literally ask me
how many people check all those boxes
like I've met one person in my life you
right and there's other people that I've
talked to who like are very unique in
that they sit at the intersection of
these things but most people don't know
how to interact with compute like
they want to put you in a box right and
when you can't be put in a box some
people are like very threatened by it
other people are intrigued by it but it
is this like very weird thing because
most people you could put in the Box
yeah right now you may be wrong about
the Box you put them in but like for
most folks you're like okay who are your
conservative friends you're like got my
five friends who are your liberal
friends I got my five friends right yeah
when you know someone can be put in the
Box the reaction that people have is
fascinating
we're a wild card for sure
right because they don't know how to
like if somebody listens to this and
then they meet you on the street what do
they talk to you about
they talked about ironology do they talk
to you about hey you were gay now you
think you're not gay but maybe you will
be gay hey you were engaged twice and
then broke it up like there's so many
different things that I think most
people are just like
we need more people like that right like
that's kind of the conclusion right and
I I appreciate you saying that I I want
to encourage people to be okay to look
into different things without the fear
of judgment you know uh that again I
I [__] love this life it's delicious
I get to experience what I want when I
want
when obviously when it's in alignment
with me and I do it in a way that I'd
like to believe causes no harm and can
be relatable to as many people as
possible all I'm doing is enjoying I
just carry on and I'm an inquisitive
individual I want to do I'm extremely
humanitarian if I can find a way to help
people
my energy usually goes there because
that's just my goal I want to spend my
entire life being happy and helping
other people it's it's very tough but
Society doesn't teach us that you can be
like this they all of a sudden you can
be like left turn I'm gonna go over here
try this out
look at jobs I mean I stayed in my Tech
Career I bounced out once or twice uh
but for 17 years and it was extremely
lucrative but I finally got to this
point where I was like I I'm growing
Beyond this to where I want to be able
to say
um I'm going to Ecuador and I'm gonna go
plants of trees and go take some eye
pictures and then I'm gonna go to talk
about how we can transmute Sexual Energy
and I can see Sexual Energy inside the
eye and all that like it's a I can't
just do that
here's one of my favorite things about
the eye total I took a picture of an eye
and see the Sexual Energy you can you
can see if someone is throwing that up
it's like total like what uh my my ex
and I would call it the fried shrimp
like just throw out something random and
that's that is me I'm I'm an extremely
inquisitive I want to I kind of want to
know the truth about everything and I've
never experience everything but I want
to know about pretty much as much as
possible
um because I can then relate and I can
kind of be this chameleon within
different communities which I really
enjoy because it's just the gateway to
people and I love people
uh so in the eye there's a place that's
called The Sex impulse and you can kind
of see if someone's over sexed
what does that mean
um High Sexual Energy like like they
have too much sex or as the as the
individ as what we would call in society
like a horndog right who's just I always
think about sex the audience and I both
very low I well they have a high IQ I
have a low IQ so you have to use very
simple terms so horndog or
someone who has an issue in that area
like you know we can tell if someone's
maybe had a abuse or whatnot
um it's not always the case where it's
black and white again when it comes to
iridology there's always nuances and
variances
but I I've read some people who have a
clear line within the sex impulse area
and I know right off the bat this
person's either highly sexed or they
have a big issue around sex and I love
working with highly sexed individuals
because highly sex individuals are the
most successful individuals on this
planet really yes if you take any if you
take any
um
multi you know billionaire or whatever
it is right we all know him
we've seen your girlfriend no
guys got a 500 million dollar yacht and
uh live in a different life than he was
five years ago oh absolutely yeah and
and so you you look at some of these and
this goes back to you know I was handed
uh Napoleon Hill like I said is my is my
favorite author
um but I was handed Think and Grow Rich
when I was 11 years old and it is one of
my favorite books until uh winning the
devil was released
and I love outwitting the devil even
more so because it goes deeper into
these uh the need for sex expression as
a human is the number one need need for
sexual expression and love but those are
two different things what is Need for
sexual expression so
uh so Sexual Energy or rather it it's
not technically Sexual Energy to start
with going back to that whole chakra
conversation there's this thing called
you know the the base Shocker the sacral
chakra kind of resides in that in the
area of the lower regions and
reproductive systems and such
really all the sexual energy is is
Creative Energy any day all day long
it's literally the most powerful energy
a human can create
in their being
it also can create worlds and it can
destroy worlds we've watched Sexual
Energy misused all over the place for
our entire civilization and so it's not
like a Bill Clinton situation yeah or
you know look at the the sex trafficking
we're just they're not we're not
teaching individuals how to Direct
Energy wisely and so when I get someone
who's overly sexed
usually they're pretty successful you
know because or successful at something
because that's a it's a drive it is just
I have to get this or they are having
way too much sex and that's just
Creative Energy going out the window
right like what are you actually doing
with that energy and so uh another one
of my things just going going out there
what are you going to talk about on the
road one of my favorite subjects is how
to transmute Sexual Energy
to be more successful healthier happier
stronger physically
um and it's just it's it's like the
number one thing for people who can I'm
a God on a limb is one of the things
like stop having so much sex so that you
can use the energy elsewhere yeah so
transmuting would be is um and it's not
to say that you don't have it it's a
little bit different for men and women
um biologically men every time and we
get super graphic every time a man
ejaculates he loses a little bit of his
life really yeah because men take 30
percent of their life to create sperm
right and so that's a large part of your
existence creating life-giving
properties
so you get you get men who have this
very sacred energy and this is something
this is why Fighters don't have sex or
exactly they don't have sex before the
night before why because they need all
of that they need like a camp and
sometimes it's like a month before
exactly right so there's there's
evidence in in science and biology and
obviously in the mental where you can
hone that energy a little bit and you
shift it to other areas and this is why
you see some of the most successful men
and women on earth is because they knew
hey I may not be going out there and
putting all my energy into having sex
all day long
or or whatnot or porn's a big issue also
you know where I'm just watching porn I
shift that and I went and built a
business or I went and you know built my
body up to be a brick house or I'm
healthier I'm happier I'm smarter some
of those intelligent people have shifted
that Sexual Energy to their education
you know and so you know there's if you
watch Seinfeld it's one of my favorite
shows
is the episode where Costanza George he
stops having sex because his
girlfriend's got mono and it's so funny
because you see all these examples
throughout modern society but we don't
highlight it and we know it doesn't
click because it's not taught but he
learned he suddenly now remembers
everything from high school he's now
speaking different languages he's he's
scientific now and all this and then you
get Elaine who isn't having sex and she
goes stupid
so there's these differences like uh is
there a truth there's truth to it yeah
because women Thrive or the female side
Thrive very much on if you're more of a
feminine energy uh you thrive on the
connection that's what fuels you and
that's what keeps you alive and again
women were creating the babies right so
that sexual expression is a little
different
now you get a very masculine energy
heavy woman like I have a lot of
masculine energy so I'm highly sexed
individual which means my drive is
Unstoppable I just can't stop won't stop
and when I do that's when I allow myself
to then enjoy that because one it's
[__] powerful and two I know that
I've gone and created with that energy
I'm not just using it for whatever and I
think we have a lot of misuse of that
energy in society which is one of our
biggest problems and that's why we go so
wrong uh so I can see that in the eye
and I'm inspired to to help individuals
just like tell people like yeah yeah
your Sexual Energy so like you're either
really like you like to have sex a lot
or you want to have sex a lot and you
don't or you have an issue and you don't
know what to do with that and you feel
shame around it or whatnot and usually
it's one or the other
and so it's for they know oh they know
oh I mean immediately it's one of the
biggest things that someone knows how
much they want to have sex or do have
sex or can't have sex or their sexual
issue before they know about the
lymphatic system any day so that's part
of it though because if you get that
non-physical energy flowing in the right
way you can actually find a a rapid road
to success in your health goals if you
knew about that energy it's just working
with those different levels I saw a guy
uh on YouTube which I forget his name
unfortunately he was talking about the
rise of porn especially on so many
digital platforms and uh the decrease of
masculinity in society
and the comments were split like yeah it
was all over the place not but it was
like it was fascinating right where in
terms of this it's like the more uh
accessible
that that is yeah the more Outlet
potential there is and so therefore it's
like not stored up energy that could be
used elsewhere like it was like a
fascinating way to look at it but he
didn't really get into like the science
necessarily yeah as much as this
um but like you know you start to think
about you're like yeah I bet
how many you know I I got a cell phone
when I was
I think a sophomore in high school and I
felt like a baller oh yeah right like
all my friends started getting when we
were freshmen so by talking about
sophomore I got one I was like oh man
here we go uh and for those who are
younger listening or watching this uh it
was like T9 texting it was not what uh
is available today
but uh I mean there's kids now that I
see them walking on the street they're
eight nine years old I got cell phones
yeah like and there's positives to that
like amazing you have the access of
Google right you know you see these
viral videos people using
um uh Alexa to go and you know do their
homework or whatever four or
five-year-old you're like ah like maybe
you should learn the math rather than
just ask questions yeah exactly yeah but
also there's like these downsides to it
right there's obviously the dangerous
social media or whatever but porn being
one as well and so it's like
you know cell phones I think are
probably a net positive especially for
adults but for kids as well but it does
come with these downsides that like
maybe do change society somehow right I
mean everything has a dark and a light
to it right uh same with Sexual Energy
I'm not saying I'm definitely not going
to be on the side of don't ever have it
only transmute it and I'm certainly not
going to say go out and blow wherever
you can there's always going to have
these energies and the most powerful
Energies
or I think when you look at society and
find out where they're mainly focused
you know that there is something about
that specific context that they are
worried about and or trying to explain
um
sex is
is an amazing activity
the issue is if going just like just
like the lymphatus is just like Health
go back down to the basis go back down
to the very beginning levels of it it's
Creative Energy you know there was a
time where we didn't have recreational
sex it was sex to procreate because
anytime we do that you're gonna have you
know you're gonna get pregnant you're
gonna have a baby and so it was very
conscious when you did that action
um you know why religion came in and
started to try to put laws around Sexual
Energy so you have all these different
schools of thought that'll go out and
sleep with whomever and do whatever and
explore and that's the spiritual way to
do it or you know then you got the
religious side that's like nope wait
until you're married don't do an unless
you only want to have babies and and so
when when I sat back and looked at it as
I was very young when I got really
intrigued with sex because I was a
highly sexual child and I didn't quite
understand why that was and so as I and
I've never still to this day not one one
night stand
I naturally did that but I think it's
because I picked up that book and sex
was always a big No-No in the family
because we were raised born again
Christian
don't say the word don't watch any
movies in it everything was Hush Hush
and I'm over here like
so I'm real Curious now what is it like
why is it saying no because if you're
saying no I want it I want to understand
what that is I was very rebellious
sex is simply expression but it's
expression of very very powerful energy
and we can you know like porn I'm not
the biggest fan because I look at men we
need men to have in our to encourage
them to
not waste their life force energy but to
use it wisely and I think we're actually
damaging men to his point by just
allowing this access and basically
encouraging them to do that I don't
judge a guy who does look at Society
it's what we've trained them to do at
any given point in time go check out
this girl go Lander go or guy whatever
you know gay community we'll see um it
doesn't really matter but go out there
get it take care of it and now you're
good get rid of the urge well the urge
is just that knocking
I got something bigger do something with
this this is like starting to get that
urge if you realize that that urge if
you just sat with it for a second it's
kind of like hunger if you just sat with
it for a little bit you'd find more
clarity and you'd find a better drive
and you'd kind of like get some more
insights about what to do with that as
opposed to just going and putting it
somewhere yeah so it's you know it's
it's definitely it's I I don't I don't
think in this lifetime you know Napoleon
Hill
was a genius in my opinion and uh what
he was trying to convey to this world
but that conversation even in my
lifetime I'm not sure we're gonna fully
even be able to understand it I would
like to bring out some more what's going
on I hope that you're enjoying this
conversation without it was super
fascinating I really enjoyed it as well
unfortunately Elle and I talked about a
couple of things that YouTube doesn't
really like and so we've had to cut it
out of the interview but rather than
simply cut part of the interview and not
let you know that something's missing I
decided that we should tell you when
we're being censored right now it's one
of those times Elle and I are discussing
something that YouTube doesn't like you
might see me again later on in the
conversation but I wanted you to know
that something in the interview got
changed let's get back into the
interview with Elle I hope you guys
enjoy the rest of the conversation where
can we send people to find you on the
internet because I think there's going
to be a lot of people talking to you
pictures of their eyes well they got
other questions uh so uh best thing to
do I mean obviously social media is
fantastic I'm bigger on Instagram show
me your set and uh for those that didn't
hear that's literally her Instagram show
me your set thank goodness up until now
don't get any wise ideas everyone else I
have not seen any other sets than the
eyeballs
um but you know me I that's that's
that's the you gotta get playful with
this right so show me your set.com show
me your set on Instagram and yeah that's
those are the best places to find me
it's where I usually put most of my
content and so forth so yeah awesome
well I appreciate it very much for you
coming on uh I really enjoyed the
conversation today I learned a ton uh I
feel uh I was dumb when I started now
I'm a little less dumb but uh I think
people really have enjoyed this and
we'll definitely do it again in the
future no I appreciate it thanks for
having me on and I love what you're
doing with your your podcast and and the
conviction around how you're going about
it you know and bringing value add to
the world you know I'll end with this
I would I live by a philosophy and it's
render useful Service First
in the amount of everything that you
require and want and desire on a
material Level
but render that Service First
so thank you for doing what you're doing
and it's been a pleasure to be here and
I've had a blast thank you awesome all
right thank you everyone